all right and we are live the last word
with lord cognito
and ibantis fresh on that friday morning
campfire
what's going on you look like i got a
nice little special guest lined up today
man
yeah we had some crazy stuff going on in
the week um
obviously the internet was in a bit of a
frenzy waiting on pins and needles for
what we expected on tuesday morning and
it dropped
so before we talk about all that good
stuff because we do have a lot to
discuss
as lots of things are coming around the
corner let's get this episode started
the only way we know how welcome
to the last word number 135. once again
we have been chosen
content creators are working in a frenzy
and even a on exotics might be good
the next chapter of the next chapter of
destiny 2
is just around the corner and we are
joined by a great guest to discuss the
events of the week
this man started gaming with one of the
goofier looking eye
consoles but it was an icon the n64
that console helped change the game and
turn this man into a gamer
he has enjoyed a mix of games throughout
the years shooters of course are a tread
and true part of his gaming history
but sports games are right there as well
with a special love for fifa
and of course a good mix of
single-player adventure thrown in as
well
of course gaming is what can bring us
together but this man has a much
bigger seal of approval on his content
creation bag than most of us gamers
a true filmmaker for music videos
wedding montages
and commercials so you know
uh you you may never know where you're
going to see one of his videos next
so without further ado let's welcome a
member of team ahamkara
i always butcher this one masenkoa it's
cool i don't know
i'll have to ask co-host of his own
podcast destiny nerds
partner with gamer sups and artesian
builds creation studio owner pokemon
card addict owner of an epic beard and
even more epic dance moves
the one the only bearded luke how you
doing sir
what's up thanks i'm great that was a
super cut
i was like i wonder why i had to write
some stuff down i get it now you just
gave me the best intro anyone's ever
given me in my life
appreciate that that's what we if you
clip anything from the show take it with
you
i'm just taking that first part making
that my channel trailer
on twitch it's like who is bearded luke
he he said it i'm just gonna take his
this guy said it it was perfect i
appreciate it
i'm doing great though i'm excited to be
on here uh i don't get to be on podcast
super often so i'm super excited to
chat about destiny it always ends up
being destiny i always
i tell all my friends and my family it's
so cool like they're like what do you
i don't get it why do you stream on
twitch i'm like i like gaming
in this game so much that we talk about
it on the internet for hours
with each other
and listen to it so i'm excited about it
so i appreciate it i appreciate it i've
had my parents ask me like what are you
what's the link to the podcast i'm like
you would be so bored
yeah like it is not for you it's like
i'd be like oh let me talk about this
game and everything
you would hear my voice the words would
sound like another language i swear
yeah but there's passion there
that's your brother yeah man let's get
right into it
tremendous history checking out a lot of
stuff you put down and um
before we get into the filming i want to
focus on the gaming side with you
because it's like it's so cool like
you kind of had a different path you
know as far as
like jump jumping into uh destiny and
stuff like that so what are some of
those early
if influences i know we talked n64 but
give us some more you know early
influences that really got you in the
game
yeah so i still remember in
like in preschool i was i went to this
place called la petite for preschool
which sounds fancy
i think i've seen one of those yeah
they're not super fancy they sound like
it but
there there was a uh super nintendo
there and people played mario on it
nice and i never played i just watched i
was like that looks fun but cause i was
like a little kid but i remember seeing
it and then a lot of my gaming
experiences before i even got an n64 was
me watching people play games like i
would always just be in the living room
watching watching watching like never
actually being a lot of yeah
twitch viewers
yeah and then i um basically it was
n64 and then the playstation 2. my
friend i remember
me buying an n64 first and i just wasn't
good at it i was too young i was like
super young when i got it so i was
playing donkey kong i couldn't even get
past like the first level like i don't
even
i never beat it i know i couldn't i
couldn't figure it out
i just had one because everyone else was
talking about it because it was the hype
and then when i started getting a real
gaming it was
the playstation 2 came out and uh i was
playing
like there was this uh
what what are they called atv game like
four-wheeler game yeah that i was
playing with my friends
where you would just if you drove it as
far as you possibly could
like until the map ended it would like
fling you
like it would like literally fling you
as high in the sky and like it was nutty
and i always thought it was the funniest
thing so that's like
it's i don't know why i only remember
that from my early game
oh no yeah from like arcades whatever i
think it's off-road whatever had the
four
steering wheels and it was like the four
little rally trucks that would go around
it was kind of isometric view
that one always still success is a
random game that was like i always had
fun with that one because you like
kind of be drifted around this like dirt
in the corners and stuff there's certain
random things that are like oh yeah
mm-hmm yeah absolutely it's it's there
was that and then there was
kingdom hearts i remember playing and
not having any idea what was going on
again that was a really good and this is
a really good example of
me now and then so i'm known for with my
community and my friends for i
i'm efficient when i game and i know
what i'm doing but i typically
am pretty lost when it comes to a lot of
things i'm like what's going on what am
i doing
it takes me a little bit longer to
connect but so like
kingdom hearts was very confusing when i
was a kid too but it wasn't until like
i got past like all those i did a lot of
single player stuff i didn't even know
what like i didn't even know these
things could connect like consoles could
connect
to internet until uh call of duty modern
warfare
uh that was the first time i ever knew
that you could even play into the real
world
there was all this time i didn't even
know i had a i had an hdtv
and i had a xbox 360. i didn't even know
that
you plugged hdmi into the tv and it
would look better i was using the
the three the the component cables for
like years
oh man rgb there
before i knew anything about tech and
then i remember the day i plugged an
hdmi in i was like
oh my god transform when you saw 720p
for the first time oh my god
what is this yeah i remember those days
man
yeah yeah the first tech upgrades were
like
you like your first hd tv and you're
like
brother i remember man like he's talking
about language because it's like
composite video remember s video oh
absolutely
yeah like we were like blown away by
these like little steps these
incremental steps in clarity and video
quality
but yeah like what what do you say i
remember in the you know ps2
360 era and all that like when you
finally seen
you know hdmi and you finally you know
you start to
get that full when you go from the 480i
and then you go up to 720 you're like oh
oh this is cloudy this is different
yeah this was different for sure let's
continue it i was just going to say
that's one thing even chat said it too
is like
and you cut your teeth you saw super
nintendo and then n64
that's 16 bit to 64 bit and then of
course now we're in a whole different
level of insanity but like it's so weird
to think about
8-bit 16-64 like the leap in
progressions used to be like
holy crap every time and now we're like
well now we're going down to these these
pixels
and the rain tracing's a little more and
you're like everything's a little more
nuanced now and like when you were
growing up like every console was like
a holy crap jaw on the floor and it's
just like we are
we're not gonna get those until you like
step into vr and it's just like oh i'm
in real life i can smell those i can
smell the things that are
yes 5d you're like every sense is going
why are my feet tingling what's
happening
i'm being touched i'm being touched
don't take that out of context everybody
please don't flip that
won't let me clip that right here
that's the title of the text
it's monetized and cancelled i do
remember one thing so since
you guys all remember this obviously you
know when the game's not working you
pull it out and you blow on it
my wife the other day i'm gonna make a
tick tock out of it she was like
trying to get something to work on her
phone and she pulls her phone up and she
goes
and then she takes the cable and she
goes come on
so it's like you know you're a 90s kid
when yes yes absolutely
yes that was the era i'm an 80s kid
so i don't know i was born in 92 i'm a
baby
he's got me by a few more than that so i
know he's
78 so yeah this is definitely i was the
disco errors
he was doing disco back when i was oh
that's awesome
came out dancing he's doing he was doing
this and this
that's when that came out bell bottoms
afro it was like though it was party
they have fun in my era man
barton argued lots of fun lots of other
things
too yes yes other things what happened
she's gonna leave out the other thing
leave it at that really
luke but yeah it's like honestly like
your journey has been kind of cool to
get to what you do but
i was like i know gaming is definitely a
thing and you definitely got hooked on
call of duty as a shooter destiny sunk
his teeth in
and yet somehow because i s you are one
of the few i've got to say
everybody there's so many people ask
like hey what's the question what's your
gaming history
there's one game that's always in there
since a lot of people play destiny
you haven't touched this one game
haven't
touched it and it's halo yeah yes i was
surprised
and i don't know if that's one of those
have at this point has it been so long
are you like afraid to get into it
because you're like
it's been too much or just i mean you're
busy enough as it is but i'm just kind
of curious is it one of those like
on your backlog you're like i kind of
eventually want to or you're good
without it i'm just kidding curious
yeah it's it's more of
i want to play it now uh i
i never play so i think it's not like i
never touched it i i
like tried it with my friends
multiplayer when i was younger and i
just wasn't interested
and i literally i'm just going to tell
you it was because whenever you did
whenever i press the what is it the left
trigger it wouldn't zoom in
i was like i'm good i don't want to play
yes
[Music]
yeah and modern warfare was just i don't
know i always have really liked
realistic
obviously i for whatever reason i really
liked the realistic shooting
games for whatever reason i don't know
why and like you could jump real high
and it was all futuristic i don't know
i just never got into it i wish that i
did now that i
love destiny so much because i whenever
we talk about it i didn't like destiny
at first either so it's
it's kind of like uh in that route but
i've been talking with a couple of my
friends i really want to
play all of them like i'd love to do
like a full thing where i go
from the first one all the way to the
last time yeah i'd love to play the
campaigns and i've heard so many good
things about them uh
my attention span just isn't as as good
as it used to be with games like i used
to be able to play anything
for as long now i can i can play for
about 20 minutes i'm like
i think i'm gonna go play destiny again
i don't know if that's because i'm
addicted to that
that just sounds like a drug addict yeah
i get
crap for it all the time we'll be like a
plain god of war or something so
good with my buddies or streaming
i'm like this is fun i want to finish
this but i really want to go
do a gm i don't know why but
that's the dusty hooks man god of war on
god of war mode that's a gm for you holy
hell oh gosh
i can imagine well yeah i haven't played
it but i want to
eventually it's not because i hate it i
just i think i just missed it i think i
just missed the like wave
oh i did that my i have a couple big
sacrilege mine's mass effect but i
actually get a chance for it to come
back in 4k
so that's my big one that everybody
around me has always said like
literally probably top five series or
stories that they played in games for
mass effect and i'm like
and i missed the whole train and then i
wouldn't have played it either
well matt remastered coming back so
may both of you may 14th okay
both of you get that corrected
okay put in my calendar yes please that
is
oh my god that's like in the pantheon of
greatness
what we're gonna get a new season may
11th
that's the problem right there that's
what happens
that's always the problem we'll have to
see
i'm hoping like may and june right now
don't have a ton of stuff
i mean there's plenty of things that
don't have a release date but i'm hoping
that like
may june july like that summer section
isn't too
stacked with anything big because stuff
like that
feels like it would fit there because
the summer season is probably going to
be smaller for destiny
vault of glass will be the big thing i
think it'll be kind of the in between
before like the witch queen lead up and
stuff and
i'm hoping i at least gotta play the
first one
one or two like one and two or like is
i've seen people debate
two's pretty like people tend to lean
two but one and two are
generally both thought of pretty well
um but yeah i was like three would be
the one like i've heard people like uh
no
like not always amazing three is amazing
the problem is
they were doing something so unique and
carrying over your progress
choices per you know perma-death there's
so many things
what happened was three was amazing it
just would it got to the
end the last like two couple hours
they put the cherry on the sundae all
the way and for people who spent so many
time so much time with these characters
they felt a little betrayed like how you
know so it was so bad the outcry was so
bad they
actually had to make a dlc which added
more content to the ending of the game
it was like a 15 gig patch to an
extended
ending to kind of satiate it there was
an uproar
about that because massive three was
awesome but it just again it was the
ending
and the choices involved at the end and
how i guess people felt it was shorter
not
enough meat to it to end this the
trilogy the right way
oh yeah it was something man but yeah
but you guys got to touch those games
man
classics bro classics for sure
heck yeah what about you cog yeah man
that's so i wanted to
finish talking with him as far as that
and then um you know obviously
being a filmmaker you know what i'm
saying and i thought that was like
really unique because
you know obviously you have your own
career in what you're doing
and and then to sit there and say okay i
also want to translate
transition into content creation so
let's start with that like um
what was the like the flip of the switch
so to speak so you're like okay
i want to now also do this in terms of
you know destiny and gaming
yeah it's a it's it wasn't that long ago
actually that
that happened i've i've always i went to
college for
uh this is funny i always tell this
story in it don't judge me for this okay
so
i went to college for a journal i didn't
like do video my whole life i filmed
like stuff on my little camera when i
was a kid
but um the in college i went to school
for journalism
and there was a class that i had where
there there was this professor that made
us take uh these little mini quizzes
before class like it was at 8 am class
and he would make us read the newspaper
from the local town like this little
tiny town and
he would ask questions about articles in
that newspaper
it's 8 a.m like i'm not reading the
newspaper i agree
barely here i'm barely here where am i
supposed to get the newspaper from you
know what i mean
you better even get that from this
exactly
is it a news stand does it show up on my
door how do i do this
i gotta be out there waving at six a.m
on the porch exactly i love that 90s
baby's kicking it i love it
i love it he he he does this quiz and
most of the time i
i sometimes would read i wouldn't read
them but i would look at the titles of
the articles
well one couple of the times i didn't
and no one did in the class so
there would always be one kid that did
so we all cheated off each other you
know like
like yo what is it overlooking what is
that
and uh one day i came into class and the
dude had three of my quizzes and three
of this other kids quizzes and he's like
these look exactly the same
because the wrong answers are gonna be
you know you're cheating if the wrong
answer is the wrong answer
cause it's a made-up wrong answer from a
story that you don't know about
he's like i got you have two options you
you can either get kicked out of school
right now
or you can option you can you can
whatever opportunity is
yeah or you can leave the journalists
department you're going to not only get
a c in this class but you have to do
double news articles so i had to write
90 news articles that that semester i
also had to write a letter to the editor
about why i was a cheater and they
posted it in the newspaper
they behaved and shaped you they made a
public example of
yes holy crap so the reason i say that
is because i
had to get i was kicked out of the
program so i had to pick up another
class during that semester
and there was only one class it was
called video practicum and i was like i
guess i'll do that
and they gave me a camera and it was
just like oh this is meant to be so then
i just kept
i just kept doing video video video like
i'm not going to explain that whole
story but basically i just
it was my gift i'm pretty okay at it so
i just kept doing it
started a business called alc
productions in college because
i was like i can't uh i don't think i'm
gonna be able to afford i'm a
communication major you don't make
a lot of money when you get out of
school so i'm like i have all this i had
like 95
000 of student loan debt i found out
about when i was a senior i was like
i'll show you brother
i was like so we started this business
and um we started filming weddings then
and then that's kind of just morphed
into what i do now which is pretty
awesome
so cool what happened so i do video and
that's that's
how it started well now we'll go go all
the way to 2019
in the summer time which is funny
because i saw both of you there before i
knew who you were
at guardian guardian con yes so i was at
guardian con that's how
i follow i think abont has followed me
or something on twitter i followed him
on twitter and i saw you guys walking
i'm like that guy looks familiar but i
don't
i didn't talk to anyone listen i went to
guardian con
for the first time ever i i i started in
2019
the beginning of 2019 i started watching
no 2018
one of those years i started watching
twitch and i was literally only
following
king athalian i thought his stuff was
cool i watched a lot of youtube videos
like more console and unknown player i
watched those kinds of guys on youtube
and then i was like always like oh
that's cool and i did youtube stuff not
in the gaming realm it was always like
film making like having
tutorials which i actually don't like
making so like i was never able to stick
with it because i was like
it's tough whenever you film stuff to
want to teach people how to
do it so i'm still like are really good
at it i just want to make stuff and then
show people what i made
but anyways sorry i'm going on and on
here know basically this is your time
okay so we get to guardian con we
basically i'm watching on twitter i i'm
following some gaming stuff
i i always gamed growing up and it was
fun and it was cool and
i didn't really follow gaming content
until act until destiny so
uh i'm i'm playing destiny i'm following
along with that journey with a couple
people online
i watch king italian because i found him
because of a it was literally because
there was i was trying to watch one of
the bungee live events on twitch
and i saw his name at like the top of
the list i was like who's this guy so i
watched it and then
i was like oh this is interesting i
didn't know people did this this wasn't
that long ago like this was just a few
years ago
and i kind of just watched and i watched
that he had
uh whenever it was destiny khan before
like i was watching it online happening
and then no
see it was like i threw all the exactly
the details
and then i finally got to the point
where i was like okay guardian con's
happening
i don't have a wedding that weekend i
can book it
because it i want to go and see what
this is all about these people seem to
be really cool so i showed up
and it was nuts because i just saw all
these communities of people that were
just there
like that knew each other and loved each
other and like
were wearing t-shirts with their twitch
names on it and all this sweet stuff
yeah this guy and i saw both of you
there
which is crazy because i didn't know you
at all i saw a lot of people that i know
now there that
i didn't know then and i'm sitting there
and i'm at this and it was a good time
i'm i was a little bit more shy because
i just didn't know i'm i'm like
extroverted in some ways and introverted
in a lot of ways it's kind of like a
weird mix
and there's just a lot of really nice
people that i met there and then
i'm sitting there i'm like man this is
it i got to do this because i always
kind of tinkered with the idea like if i
just bought like this one thing that
connected my because i was always like
i wasn't the kind of guys like i'm just
gonna turn the stream on and start i'm
like i gotta make it look good exactly
exactly
there you go so i'm like i'm at guardian
con and i'm on amazon during one of the
events i'm buying a cam link 4k
a capture card like all this stuff he's
going oh he's ready yeah
exactly and i got back from
i got back from guardian con and i'm
like i'm going to do this i'm going to
be a streamer
i want to also i'm this is a little bit
different too because i was like
there the whole time and i was like when
i come next time i want to be able to
have friends that i know from the
internet
and i also told myself i'm going to be
filming this next year because i felt
like i wanted to be a part of it
yeah because every time i'm at an event
that i'm not filming i feel a little
uncomfortable because i like to have a
camera in my hands
i'm like okay i'm gonna go ahead and i'm
gonna message
kevin and say listen i i'm good so i'm
gonna
message him and see if i can get
information about how to get on a team
so i i text
i message him in all caps i put i'm
filming guardian
con or i'm filming gcx 2020 and uh
i sent him this long thing with all my
information and he sent me an email
immediately and
tagged the content like their their
their video guy that does all their
stuff at guardian
and said he'll hit you up if he needs
anything i'm like i'm not waiting for
that so i messaged him
and then it's the same kind of thing and
he texted me and he's like hey dude i'd
love to talk tomorrow so then we got on
the phone and we talked
and they we had like a really good
conversation he was like we want to like
i was like i will do it for free and i
just want to be on your team he
ended up hiring my company to come and
shoot it for this year's
but then this year's got cancelled
somehow it worked whenever i was like
i'm gonna do this like if you're a
little bit bold i guess it works
sometimes
but uh so you gotta shoot yourself right
the problem is i've had so much fun on
twitch this past year
that now i think it'll be fun to film
but i really just wanna hang out with
all you guys
a legendary classic man a lot of fun
it's just such a cool environment you
know all these content creators we all
love this game and just to see everybody
in one space having a great time
and then on top of that bungie actually
going out there to the events themselves
and your shoulder to shoulder with the
people who make the game you love like
dude tremendous story i was it's
interesting to hear you say like yo you
saw us
you knew who we were like that's
mind-boggling to me you know
i remember my first time too and i was
just like wow it was it was it was
sensory overload but i was happy i was
just like yo this is so
cool i can't believe there's so much
people here
in a community here that loves this
thing as much as i love it like
tremendous man i hear you yeah yeah it
was awesome i
had a great time and that that led me
into doing this
which is right now it's just it started
off as just streaming on twitch now i'm
starting to push
this just this year i started pushing
into the youtube game which is like
i've done i've tried several times like
with my own personal
channel i've done like the oh it's funny
my most popular videos i've ever made
are like the lamest videos i've ever
made it's like
a video about my car when it came out
because it i just i like to tr we like
to travel so we
got a rooftop tent and so like when we
travel we can put the tent on there
i did a video that wasn't even edited it
was literally just
me undoing the top of the thing to show
it open and it has like
25 000 views or whatever on my personal
channel
and then like our wedding channel like
we we've been really successful in
columbia i live in columbus ohio
so i'll dox myself i don't care but
if they find you in a city the good luck
yeah i mean
my business is really my address used to
be my business it was super easy to find
out where i live to be honest but i
don't live there anymore so good luck
finding me but
the uh we're pretty well known in
columbus for our wedding videos just
because we've been around so long and
i think our stuff's pretty good so we we
we do that
and i don't remember where i was going
with this
uh basically uh oh yeah we have a
youtube channel there and that's a
popular that has a lot of
like it's a popular channel just because
i like clickbait the crap out of stuff
like
emotional wedding crying like that kind
of stuff
like that best
first looks 50 000 views like that kind
of thing so
i kind of love the idea of what youtube
is but now
i'm i'm kind of pushing my my like this
last year was just
i'm gonna try twitch i'm gonna do it
when my wife goes to bed i'll stream
late at night that's why i stream so
late
uh and and then now i'm trying to see
what else can i add to it so that's why
we started a podcast on sundays which is
super fun because i just love talking to
different content creators
and then now i've been opening pokemon
cards on on video and postings yeah
so you've got like that has been what is
a few months now i feel like the pokemon
cards
why is there such a resurgence and that
just give me a quick
like 60 second reasoning because i mean
yeah i grew up with like pokemon red and
blue and i feel like there may have even
been cards but like
what why is is there like a why is it
big
i'll tell you why for the people who
don't know including me
yeah same question
it's super simple and it's super lame at
the same time logan paul
he's the reason it happened i don't know
if you guys know he's very
no i've never heard that name yeah you
might probably want to
but he bought a he made a video
where he bought a first edition a base
set
booster box and then it the vi the video
had like 10 million views it basically
just
showed that he got back into pokemon and
he was opening all these old cards and
then
he was showing content creators to do it
i saw the video and i was like i didn't
know that
that pokemon was still around because i
i opened i had so many cards when they
came out like
that was like a kid so like all base set
i made it all the way through like
neogen neogenesis or whatever the the
cards were at the time and
uh but then i just stopped because i was
growing up and now
now he he made all these he made this
video and then he did a live stream
where
people bought each booster pack for
eleven
thousand dollars and he live streamed
opening each pack
wow and there was like three hundred
thousand concurrent viewers they raised
like five hundred thousand dollars for
charity wow that's awesome and it just
popped off like i think a lot of people
that really liked pokemon at the time
saw it and then they realized there's
like a whole entire community of content
creators that
make videos opening cards and then they
also you could also see
the stuff's more valuable than it used
to be like it's that card the whole card
game
and it's funny because at the same time
i went i so i just started making videos
about it and then
my uh in town i work the town i live in
there's a card shop i went to go buy
some cards at and the dude
the dude is like huge on online i like i
i looked online at this shop because i
wanted to go find it dude has like 50
000 followers on instagram
and like massive interactions and it's
not like pokemon it's like sports cards
so he puts a thing on a story and says
i'm looking for a guy
i need i need a video guy i got a big
project i'm working on
so i'm like i'm like hey dude it's me
cards yeah i love cardstock messages
video cards yes yes i mean he's like he
doesn't message me back but then i find
out his wife
i just i went to school and lived on the
same street as his wife and she told him
about me so he reached out to me
so now i'm filming a mini doc series
about this dude
who he bought a new building and he's
moving his card shop there
so it's just funny like because i'm now
seeing like the inner workings
of sports card industry there's so much
money in it it's insane i think that's
probably a big caveat to why people are
doing this because there's money
involved i'm doing it just because
i think pokemon cards are sweet and it
makes me feel young like it makes me
feel like a kid and i like doing a lot
of stuff that makes me feel like a kid
as an adult
so i guess that's probably that was
longer than 60 seconds but i i hate to
say it's logan paul and logan paul just
came out the video on wednesday
he bought six first edition booster
boxes for two million dollars and he is
auctioning them off
auctioning packs off one by one and he's
going to do a big giant
live stream on february 20 something and
that
is going to be like another resurgence
and it's just a bunch of eyes that
didn't see pokemon are seeing yeah i
think that's why fair enough
it's probably a fad but it'll probably
go away eventually probably
it seems lasted longer than gamestop
stock so that's fine
that was pretty quick that that'd
definitely yeah man all what i was gonna
ask you too is that um
you know obviously you said getting into
a bottom warfare that was you that was
your baby then
you switch over then this destiny thing
grabs you but what i thought was
interesting was like
the fact that it was king's fall
oh yeah and i like it
relax yourself i know you love this part
so i gotta ask him these questions but
like you have a unique
you have a unique uh you know start and
um
i want you to break down how like
influential
why was kings fall it fee what was the
hulk what
what was the first couple of things
what's the name no i'm just kidding
i'll i'll just i'll explain how i
started because me starting
with destiny will make this part make
more sense okay i
i uh played the alpha because someone
told me to and i didn't like it i played
the beta because someone told me to and
i didn't like
it i like this too much like halo and
that game's dumb
thank you
[Music]
yeah so then the night that bungie
that that destiny's launching i just
wanted to go to taco bell which was
next gamestop so i went to taco bell i
bought tag
i was like what's the what's the order
we got to know the order
i wasn't pre-ordering it my friend was
pre-ordering it he's like i'm going in
town to get destiny i'm like i want taco
bell so i went
with him how many how much what was the
taco bell order or what's your usual
taco bell order
you're gonna judge me so hard for this i
ordered ten i ordered ten
fiery doritos logos tacos at the time i
ate all ten of them oh my god
in college ten and i'm not a very big
dude i paid for that in the next day
yeah so then we go to gamestop and he's
i'm like
i'm like ah i guess i'll get it so i
also got it
and we we went back to the dorm or we
had a townhouse
and played i got to level 20 and then i
was like well that's it okay cool
so then i i i traded it in for a shadow
of mordor
oh this is hilarious this is awesome i
don't know this game i'm gonna go play
lord
and then we i traded it and then my
buddy
who got me into it he kept playing he
kept playing i remember when he was
doing
vaulted glass the first day he called me
like dude i've been doing this raid for
six hours i'm like
six hours i've never even played a game
for six hours long
what are you doing and but i didn't get
it yet i knew i was gonna get it
eventually
and then we i got married i was like
i graduated college and it was like a
really fast pace because this game came
out like when i was a senior in college
and then
i graduated early and then i got married
and moved into an apartment
and i was playing fifa and i was in a
party chat on ps4 with my dudes that
played destiny
and i just kept hearing them going like
oh my gosh this game's crazy oh my oh my
god i'm like man i feel like i'm missing
out on something like that game was not
fun
and then i i just didn't get it yet
because i didn't understand what this
was
so then there was like you could
download destiny for free
like a bait like a like a trial where
you just had
earth yes the cosmos so i did that and
there was like those key things it was
during house of wolves there was
those key run things where you would get
like oh yeah if you sprint if you like
got in your sparrow went really fast you
could go get some loot
yes and i got uh my first ever legend
it was a legendary cloak and i was like
ooh
what is this because i didn't i didn't
give it enough time to get anything good
like even
anything purple when i played it the
first time i just got to level i was
just like you're typical wow
boring game who played bass story just
blues and
and then you wouldn't do the story and i
was like well that's it i guess because
i didn't understand luther shooter i
never played that kind of thing i mean
you shared it
you should continue i just usually
played the campaign and i was like
that's it i guess yeah because you truly
like it's a normal single-player
campaign experience and it's over
right and i remember being disgusted as
well i was like oh that's the hype with
this
i don't get it continue yeah and so i
move i move
i i i hear that i'll get that loot i'm
like
i heard my friend his name's a doctor
shabby he plays with me all the time
still
he was like he was like ooh i think
bungie gotcha like i remember him saying
and i was like
the next day i'm i'm i'm at this i lead
a small i also work at a church so i
lead
i was leading a small group at the time
for like students and i'm like does
anyone here
have destiny and they're like this kid's
like my friend has it and he'll sell to
you for ten dollars
so i gave him ten bucks he run down runs
down the street and gets destiny one
you can see that oh my
you went to your church group and said
you're holding who got that game that i
got rid of
used game sales shout out for the 10
hustle shout outs off the game
i respect that so now you get it back
i got it back and i'm playing i'm
playing it and i remember the first
thing i was like
you know how there was like levels like
if you got to like level three in your
vanguard you could buy the legendary
armor and all i was about i was like i
want the legendary armor i need to buy
it
so i remember i thought i was grinding
so hard i'm like i'm gonna get to level
two
i'm gonna get to level two in my
vanguard
it's gonna be nutty i get to level two
and i'm like oh
that's that's not it so then i bought i
bought um
you know house of wolves and uh the dark
below
and the next thing that came out was
king's fall so i got my i was just i got
in
like i remember my wife went on a
mission strip and i
i played destiny in the apartment by
myself for
like five days straight like i was just
like
all night playing destiny destiny
destiny destiny like getting loot
getting world of warcraft episode you
haven't showered in four days be like oh
white's gonna be on tomorrow i gotta
clean up
basically it was gross i was gross that
week and
i got i got into it i got i got into
i i watched a bunch of videos like a ton
of videos and i just
understood the game and then they and i
started announcing all the stuff for
king's fall and then at it like the way
it launched
it launched at like 4 00 a.m that
so like and i had a regular nine to five
job i wasn't like doing
what i do now i work for myself now at
first i was working for this like weird
studio place
it's not important but i had to wake up
and go to work so me
and my friend doc and my friend shane we
woke up and we played
uh we played we played king's fall like
right in the morning like
i've never seen it was ready soon as the
release window was like you could
download it i mean you could play
yeah and we we had like i remember like
saving up there was even like this there
i don't remember if you guys remember
but there was like these codes that you
could put in and you would have like
extra xp
and postmaster for king's fall
into the tower and we were level 40 or
whatever like
we all because they changed it to light
level yes
king's fall and i don't know dude
whenever i played it it was just the
campaign the music
the the locations the dark the dark
feeling that it brought i was like
and it was my first time really getting
to play a new thing in destiny other
than whenever i didn't like it at the
beginning i like was fully in
and it happened to be a time whenever
there was just such good strikes and it
just it felt like the universe was
changing
you know what i mean like it was
everywhere the taken were popping up
they would appear on the map and all
that yeah it was just
there was just so much and that's what
like pulled me in and then that was my
first ever raid that i did
like i did the other raids but it was
just more like all right just stand
there and do this this is the first time
where i got to like figure out what it
was
and alex raiding was when i did vog
that was like the first time i that was
part of the reasons i stuck to destiny
was
there's nothing there's i mean there's
probably other things like that i'm just
a little bit
uh i don't know about other games as
much when it comes to like
co-op but like having six players
that all have to communicate with each
other to do something no matter
what you know
i'm like this is insane like this is
this is not
like anything else i'm gonna i'm gonna
commit my time to this now
then i started seeing invest how
investment works in it
like it shows for it in some ways or
another i mean not as much nowadays but
like yeah we'll talk about that but
that's fine
yeah the investment in this game just oh
man it blew my mind and especially with
king's fall just being the way it was i
just the loot was good i don't know
there's just so much that like it was
like a perfect storm
for me personally that's probably why i
like king's fall even more than i
probably could have but holy cow and
just orcs was like
such a hardcore boss like just his voice
and it's just so much so yeah that's my
long-winded version of
why i like him amazing it's amazing
it's so unique to hear that story
because
again what's even more unique is how
many times you rebuked
destiny yeah you rejected that away
like for you to come back to me just
shows
it's something about that game because i
i've heard similar story not to yorick's
day but
you know i even myself you know what i'm
saying which was like yo i don't get it
i'm planning like a regular game
you know kind of thing but it's so funny
when the hooks get in oh yeah and you
see that person transform and i've seen
it in people about claire now and it's
like
you know i'm going to use the clown
destiny and then you get them in and you
get
whatever that content is that hooks or
like you said in your case with the
legendary
you know i've seen it when a person
finally breaks through and gets that
first
exotic and it's like that's their baby
because that was their first one you
know what i'm saying
whatever that exotic weapon and whatever
clock it's just so cool to see
but yeah with kingsville i can totally
understand where you're coming from
because
it was ominous the story led right into
the raid
you know the cinema with with uh marisol
and he
just still blew her up but whatever you
know orex was bad
he was he's a bad boy man and then
obviously the encounter himself and him
being how large in his life
he was that was a boss fight till this
day he still
as much as i'm a vague guy i will always
i think give it to
oryx case for as a as a it's kind of
like
a rage raid with the bosses the length
the time of it and then
with the culmination into one of the
greatest boss characters
that you could fight i don't have to
give it to kings for all of that so
yeah salute man tremendous this
tremendous history i love hear this
though
yeah and the story too like that's you
when you say that it reminds me of why i
like it the most like
the whole entire story getting to that
raid is what makes that raid also
special like it's not just like
most raids nowadays you just who the
heck am i fighting right now why am i
fighting him yeah we know why we're
fighting orex and we know why we're in
an ascendant
like while we were in his ascendant
realm and this and that and all it just
yeah my story is super important to me
in these games because obviously i grew
up playing story player games so like
i'm once you like really dig deep into
the lore of this game you realize
this is a deep uh universe that's like
really cool
so absolutely whenever i got into this
part like even you know just
figuring out how to get when kade's
helping you got to go get kate stash and
figure out how to get into the
dreadnought like that kind of stuff
is just it's simple but it's it's unique
and
it i just i don't know i just love it i
love destiny so much
no it's amazing you're talking to two
people that have been playing it for
way too long started a podcaster and
curse of osiris
best time by the way for that first time
evan it's not a [ __ ]
absolute worst time
yeah we have been through we've all i
mean if you've been
we've obviously seen a little bit more
of it than you because you decided at
first to be like nah
i'm gonna sell this thing back to
gamestop for my five dollars i don't
need this
i love that that taco bell is the
influence oh yeah and it's ten fire
tacos that you know that next day he's
just sitting there like oh know
he bought destiny and then the next day
just just paid for everything all in one
day whatever
yeah it's all bad but no man that's
that's as
unique of a history as i think we've had
on the podcast for definitely
somebody to finally go through and
eventually end up being hooked because
so many come through halo
and bungie's just like it's the next
progression natural progression and then
like you know they kind of get into an
rpg
most people haven't like played sports
or call of duty and then be like let me
try this destiny thing
i don't like halo at all and then
somehow like throw it
and it's you can't write that somebody
in chat was like oh it's a movie i was
like trademark last word 2020 we gotta
write that movie
uh you film it we'll shoot it i'm scared
uh somebody said it was like he's like
this movie has everything passion hate
betrayal bribing romance
literally has it all so oh man that's
that's a pretty epic history so but it's
just
it's really cool to see somebody like
you as well who's
most people will be like i want to it's
funny like your ways to get into
streaming some people like oh i turned
my playstation camera to the on and i
just like
hit live on twitch and here we go what's
up guys and then you're like
okay so what i'm going to do is take my
filmmaking gear i'm going to set this
uh nice dslr camera up i got my go xlr
got the 4k capture
i'm going to go ahead and have like you
literally started like a pro and you're
like okay i have zero viewers but i'm
the best looking guy in here
let's go well it was almost pro i still
like i was actually streaming off of my
imac at first so i had the ps4
and i had the game like the elgato game
capture
software because obs at the time didn't
work
on it worked on a mac but
you couldn't there's the capture the cam
link wouldn't work on it for whatever
reason
so uh whenever i i had that i actually
they came off some update and i just
ended up finding out it is super
terrible to stream off of an apple
product
it's they're great to use for
professional stuff like video editing
and all that but holy cow don't stream
off of them
and then about eight or nine months ago
i bought my first pc
and streamed off that and i was like man
this is cool but i'm not getting on my
frames because i'm streaming so then i
went and of course
bought another pc so now i do a dual pc
stream
because i'm like i gotta make i gotta be
able to stream in 1080p
at 60fps with all these scenes and i
wanted to
play it 1440p still i'm a little bit
extra
to be honest extra yeah he's got
his his setup you guys can't see it but
it is just
like he's decked out behind the scenes
over here so
mm-hmm yeah he's thankful for holding
onto that mic he's just like i like the
sound it's good quality doesn't matter
what it is this is my mic
yeah yeah i'm gonna get a new mic
eventually this one's good for now
though
my business helps me like the reason i'm
able to buy this stuff is because i film
so much crap all the time and then
it's like oh cool i'm filming stuff i'm
filming a video for youtube and i made
money off of it okay business expense
boom pc like you know yeah it makes it a
little bit easier hopefully the irs
doesn't hear this
that's an amazing history i don't know
if i'm going to be able to find people
who topped that but that's
that's appreciate so
before we get into this week i want to
ask because this week is obviously the
time of
trailers trailer music hype story pages
info dump all that stuff's always
pretty good time in the game as we were
leading into
this how how has destiny been for you
lately
it's been a weird season not season in
the game but season in life for me
because we just recently so i told you
about all that student loan debt
so i uh it's been a weird year obviously
for all of us covid has been
interesting but yeah the house market
for whatever reason
is got really hot during it and we
bought our house really cheap
and my wife was like hey
um what if we sold our house and then
paid off all of our debt with the money
i'm like
no that won't work so then i didn't
think about it for like five or six
seven weeks maybe more than that maybe
it was like three months and then out of
nowhere i'm like sitting there like
wait a second i'm like doing the math
that would actually work
so i talked to my one of my pastor
buddies who's also like a financial
advisor and i'm like hey
uh would this work and would your wife
his wife's a real estate agent it's just
like
perfect storm like everything he's like
dude this would work
that's gonna be crazy but let's try it
so we put our house on the market
we sell it in one day wow we make
really good money off of it and then on
my birthday i paid off every student
loan every piece of debt we had and then
we moved into our in-laws house
because we didn't have any money to buy
a new house obviously because we used it
for debt
but yeah so that during that process has
been like beyond light came out
the day that we so like the day that our
house
was bought was purchased so like i was
able to start it at my old house but
basically it was only there for like
three days and then we moved so my whole
setup
i had to actually stream and game at the
church i work at
there's like we we have it in a la old
la fitness building so like
our offices are just in this big
gigantic room that was like a
dance studio or something so extra space
they're like you can set your desk in
there for now because i just didn't have
enough space here where i'm at now right
now i'm in a renovated basement i mean
my father-in-law renovated it so i have
space which i'm super grateful for but
i was streaming over there so it was
just tough driving over there to games
so i haven't
i've played a lot of beyond light at the
beginning of the season
and then now uh i'm just getting back
getting into i got everything done i'm
like a seal guy like i'm i'm a
completionist not as hardcore as like
my buddy teasing teddy that dude's got
like oh that's a legend in here
he's a legend of the last word exactly
teddy has you know max triumph score
like that not that kind of
completionist mike scored minus one and
he's still in
the shape about that yeah yes the day
one crown yeah yeah
yeah yeah but the the this
it's been a really weird like i still
got everything done i got all my seals
done this season other than the flawless
one because i'm not doing that anymore
but that's a whole other story
so where i'm trying to get at is it's
been a weird season
i think for the game but more weird for
me because i just haven't like been
playing games as much now i'm getting
back into the rhythm but like it's been
it's been it was a really hot start and
then it kind of just was like
but i'm the most optimistic dude ever so
like to be honest with you whatever
really crazy stuff's happening destiny
that everyone hates i'm usually like
well at least we still have this game
like at least it works
i mean that's fair compared to other
things that launched in december
afterwards that didn't work so well
really that was an obvious couple
yeah so i that's where i'm right now and
it's like
i know that it's rough i've also been
around for a while now
not at the very beginning as much but
like we have had a lot of really weird
times in destiny where
it was really terrible and then i just
stuck to it and then it got better again
or
i'm just like maybe i just am too
optimistic about i don't
i think part of it is because i don't
i'm not like a full-time content creator
i don't play this game 12 hours a day
like some people
do for a living and it it would affect
that
mentality a little bit differently if
you don't have a lot of stuff to do
during that 12 hours you know what i
mean i'm like
three four five hours a night kind of
guy so like that's still a lot of time
but
i'm just i always have a lot of faith
and especially this past year being so
weird with blunt
i keep saying this i say this on my
podcast all the time and i probably sign
a broken record
but the the the the pandemic that's
happening in the world where the company
had to make stuff from home
is going to affect the way the game like
we're we're lucky we even get anything
to be honest that's how
that's how i feel i feel lucky to even
have because
do you guys remember after king's fall
we didn't get nothing until the april
update
i'm so glad luke you you're on fire
right now like literally that's that's
been my entirety lately it's just like
look i get it you know i get it you know
we love this game
and and i i came from that i came from
living in this game i came from
365 24 7. you know what i mean it's
always something and
and to see now and it's just like the
thing i'm struggling is i'm just seeing
gamers just with no
there's no empathy and no plan b you
know saying
with something that they've lived in and
the reality is games don't work like
that games generally
you know you don't play something in
that one thing
for six plus years and then have
thousands of hours in it and then
talking about
it's not entertaining me like
it's just tough for me you know i'm
saying now i get it we could be
frustrated we could we can show um hey
this needs improvement yeah we're
allowed to do that
but i i just struggle with the you know
this whole
the world is ending and you know
becoming that bungie
crazy you know what i'm saying and it's
just like slow down you know what i'm
saying
still other things to do other things to
play i get it you know what i'm saying
and it's interesting what you said about
your journey
now with your whole life what's going on
when you're doing the four to five hours
the reality is based on metrics the
majority of players are playing like you
yeah so the vocal minority who are
living in the game whether it be the
streamers the full-time or whatever you
know i'm saying that is such a small
percentage and
people have to look at the big picture
you know when it comes to that kind of
stuff because
most people fall into the category you
were in during the house
you know that's what most people fall
into you know
yeah and it's tough for like i just i
don't envy being
bungee because people have like myself i
mean i have 2 000 hours of play time in
this game
i don't can you imagine you're the only
company that you own the company
bungie is just themself and they have to
create a game that
somebody is playing for minimum 2 000
hours
and like before if i got to play a game
and it was 60 hours like that was great
okay
on the next game yeah we're over here
playing this game for five six thousand
hours
and they're like okay we gotta figure
out more content for them or they're
gonna kill us
like uh i just i i
i think of it in that in that light and
you're right like a lot of people are
not
like it's a very small percentage of the
players that are actually playing
they're just usually the most vocal
online
because they're passionate about it
which i appreciate critiquing the game
is good because it helps to get better
absolutely but i think it gets dangerous
when it gets into the part where people
are like
getting hostile towards bungie like
listen they're our friends they're
making this game for us
we should not yell at them i mean we
should
not be we shouldn't be afraid of them
but we should also like
i just respect them because they're
making something for us still
even during this weird time also like
it's probably even more difficult i just
don't know
it's until we all get to go work at
bungie and see what it's like to work
there i feel like it's kind of tough to
like
say anything really crazy about like
what's going on like i don't know if
anything this is the optimist in me
i don't know if anything's being made
for crucible but it'd be real
we we talked to clintus on a podcast the
other night and he says he knows a
couple of guys that worked there he's
like i can't imagine they're just doing
nothing
there like maybe they're working on
something i don't know
right so yeah and that's probably a not
popular opinion to be honest right now
yeah i'll be on that train with you
uh which there's just two of you guys
and it's just one truth
yeah the two of us will be at a
community summit one day because we were
so pop
we were so positive we were so positive
who were the people that were with us in
the
in the struggles those two said nice
things let's bring them in
and then you guys will be sitting next
to the other 50 people who quit the game
because they still do that so
yeah they'll bring them too why did you
quit why did you quit and why were you
smiling while you quit
i need to know oh yeah oh yeah because
bungie has an impossible job of a
franchise
and a game that has been turned on for
its seventh year now and people are and
somehow you do have a game you've
managed to keep people for
two thousand hours and there's literally
one other game that's done this
world of warcraft is the only other one
that is a franchise that has lasted this
long
and still had a decent amount of
consistency around every release
and seasons and world of warcraft's
releases are
so much farther apart farther apart
they're usually probably more
substantial but
between seasons and things but still
like the cadence of which
and that's the thing too is like you
look at a calendar
and we can get in that a little bit and
you're like hey what's the season had to
offer so far and stuff of that nature
and then you throw in kovid you throw on
those other things and believe me we
have had our fair share of
hopefully it's come across of
constructive criticism on this podcast
and not too much bashing but there are
moments where
yeah it's like there are certain
decisions that can be one thing if there
are
like true game mechanic decisions
whether it's like how fast it comes out
or slow that's like
that's a studio decision and you can
have disagreements with that and be like
hey i don't think this is the best
direction to go for the game but also as
you're saying like
we're getting something in a three-month
basis they seem to be sticking with
again it's 13 weeks season they just
told us and we're like
hey i wonder how long this season's
gonna be exactly three months ago
they're like not delayed nothing
just sticking hard and fast to it and i
don't know if they do it to themselves
or it's just something they think
they've got to do but
they have an impossible task and we may
apologize we may criticize
we may have both sides of the discussion
but no they
there's no way anything that they do is
ever going to be enough which is hard no
exactly i agree i agree tough position
to me
the the only thing like you said is just
that again like
world of warcraft in the console space
i've never seen anything like that
so um you know the the the this pure lux
longevity is just amazing that's
commendable you know to keep
interest that long keep people engaged
that long through the highs and lows
it's still to be committed and like
again we don't know the effects of the
pandemic you know like i said
i talked to different people in the
industry you know i know about uh
motion capture i know about orchestra
you know we had um
our guy skye lowing in you know he was
talking about the challenges with that
you know as far as voice actors being in
the same room there's a lot of
constraints that
really set people back and then the last
point you know we can't forget they're
an
independent studio now you know they're
independent there's no
activision mind this is all them you
know but
that's that's what i'm gonna say but i
just find it funny that people are
quitting and then the new trailer come
out oh it's on baby
they're just popping no no keep the same
energy you had
because we know bungie one thing about
them
they're marketing first of all the gun
play we already know what it is you know
what i'm saying the end game we already
know what it is you know why we love
this game you don't see the loop we know
what it is
we know why we love this game but
windham trailers it could be the worst
even with curse of osiris trailer here
we was like whoa
they know how to sell something
and it gets the feels bubbling and that
little bit of doubt you had you get
excited you're like all right i gotta
see i gotta try you come
right back and it gets you every time so
i just laugh at the people who say they
quit
because i know you're coming back you're
coming back so i'm just gonna wait about
time it's okay which dlc is gonna be
this one
or is it gonna be this fall you're
coming back you always do
you're coming back they always come back
yeah and then always come back
mm-hmm i was gonna say go ahead luke
i'll just say that
like you said like the the first tweet
is a is a screen recording of destiny
two being installed and then the second
tweeted did you see the trial
oh they brought my boy back up oh it's
on now
i don't even say i don't even call
people out noble i just sit there and
laugh
i just did because like maybe a month
ago they had an uninstall video
they made an article oh i'm quitting and
it's all so okay
cool you know we see you know do what
you got to do but you're coming back
you're coming back you can come back i
was like two i was gonna say is like
the people who get some people truly
will
get to a point where they're like
especially certain content creators like
mtac is a prime example he's covered the
game so so well for so long
he ventured out for an example and found
even greater success in something else
and for him it's the base of like
honestly his is a business decision he's
still maybe like hey there could be a
cool quest to come back for but it's
like
if i'm not doing this other thing that's
a thing and for him dude congrats like
he hit like gold with gen chin i think
is what it was mostly
but i was like for a lot of us it's like
and i'll say that in my videos like
i have been playing other things i will
still always play destiny because if
nothing else i know i want to see it to
the end
always going to see how the content is
you're going to have your ups you're
going to have your downs you're going to
have your ebbs and flows but like
the uninstall is so overly dramatic and
also as you guys have said at this time
it's been done too many times like stop
it
this is the only game that's like hey
division is like division had something
coming out now it was like
i don't even know if there was a blip on
anything
anthem god fall like out writers is
i'm leaning optimistic we talked about
it last episode where it's just because
i think it's going to be a game that's
got a good 50-hour chunk
cool leveling fun abilities like a
bespoke endgame
and it's like it's a package but it's
not a live service there will be an
endpoint
when you're done what's going to be
waiting for you again this
so it's okay to go play and experience
other things and just know that like you
want to go play some call of duty you
want to go play some god of war which
you should play
um but still this is gonna be one of
those few things
you don't have to live in it as you said
and that's gonna be the best way
is to understand that it's either you're
one of those that love
sherping which a lot of the twitch
communities like i'd love to take you
through hawkmoon motions and that was a
sad thing when you talked to um
cb last week of like some of the sherpa
missions and things that aren't in the
game that stuff does kind of hurt a
little bit but
like you can definitely help a lot of
people but if that's not your thing and
you're just i want to play a game
play it enjoy it when it's fun and only
just if you're not having fun there's a
lot of other fun things
and then when it's fun again come on
back it doesn't have to be the big
dramatic uninstall
the only time uninstall makes sense is
it if you like legitimately just don't
have enough space
on your on your computer to like
download a new game buy a hard drive
yeah or buy it but if you don't have
enough money to buy hard drive and you
can't play any other games just go ahead
and install but make sure you say that's
why i'm just kidding
i feel like i've been playing other
games recently too
and i only for me because i don't play
as much as like as i want to
once i've done all my seals and i have
all my things completed
like there's not really a whole lot of
stuff for me to do in destiny then i'll
feel i feel happy to go like i want to
play assassin's creed you see how that
rolls i want to go play some
i bought fifa again recently which is
nice that just seems to have you did you
play side you play soccer in real life
you have to
i did i did so i played soccer all the
way through college i played my whole
life
i actually wanted to go pro but i
realized in college i'm playing division
three soccer i'm definitely not going
pro
this is it he said this is the extent of
my
you had that reality check and you're
like yeah i'm like
tapped out yeah yeah absolutely
i respected though i respect that that's
funny
you would kick most people's butt on a
soccer field but you're like
david beckham even at 45 probably still
got me it's fine oh yeah
at 60 he would he would he would school
me
i'm just an american soccer player where
are we already we already have that
going against us
the females seem to do well the guys
male saw like the male u.s soccer team
struggle bus
it seems for a while that's a huge
conversation because
youth the youth programs the united
states ain't kicking it but
that's a whole other problem you're
right no you're right it's literally
what i was just about to say it's just
from a culture standpoint you know we
don't cultivate it
no i don't care about you you don't grow
up want to be a soccer player yeah be a
football player
exactly it's it's certain sports that
it's just tougher to get into in the
states because it's just it's not
growing
when you go internationally oh it's the
biggest thing in the world
these kids you're born with a soccer
ball or a football as they would call it
that makes more sense
exactly it's a different energy man and
it it really shocked me i was like wow
as i got older i saw i was like i was
living in a bubble because this is truly
the world sport
you know in my mind i'm like oh
basketball football you know
american football what did i say without
me like i'm thinking that's a big deal
but no no
side yeah yeah you've got the super bowl
and then you've got the world cup which
is
truly the world coming together so
that's always yeah yeah the every four
years
we're not in it then it doesn't matter
which happens last time
yeah yeah world cup is a different
energy bro
oh yeah oh yeah love it that was cool
yeah
yeah i was like i wish i was more into
soccer for those rare moments because
i've worked in a couple places there's
those
couple soccer players that time of year
and they just absolutely lose their mind
for certain things and you're like
oh i get it i get it dude you've never
been in like a soccer supporter like a
real soccer supporter section
it is nutty and even even in the united
states like we have
the columbus crew is in town i've been a
fan since i was a kid because
the crazy part about soccer i'm sorry
we're talking about soccer on a destiny
the united states mls started in 1996
it's only been around for like 25 years
which is insane because like the premier
league's been around for like
200 and
like we have the columbus crew and i
used to be a part of the thing the nord
deck is what it's called and there's
different supporters
sections in it so there's like la
turbina which is like the spanish
one and then there's the hudson street
hooligans and then there's the
uh crew union that's like the three that
are in there and everyone gets in
it's just like there's like chants and
it was nutty like and i'm not proud of
this but like we went to the mls cup
that they had in the crusade once and we
lost but they scored in the first
few minutes the other team did yeah and
we were in the corner and they came
over the player came over the corner
everyone was throwing full bottles of
beer at them
like throwing like all you saw was like
a rain
of like tall boy bud lights just
raining on this pla he was like oh i
really ran away
that's soccer like people getting nutty
and it's just like chance
the whole time constantly and that's
just in the united states if you go to
like old trafford and england
in manchester for a united game
75 000 people every game oh you can't
you can't well whenever there's not
coveted you can't hear
anything other than just chance
constantly and not like american chance
like let's go
team let's get no like real songs songs
real quick cuz i know we turning this
into the last
that's the soccer podcast but yo
he's about to be our last podcast
the first time i went it was on uh we
i went to the uk and then um a friend of
mine is a big liverpool fan
and we took a train from london and we
went to live was liverpool versus hall
uh it was the most insane experience
i've ever like they had a full
song this you'll never walk alone it was
it was
mine but it was it was insane i've never
seen that level of intensity and passion
for for sport and it trust me i am a big
american football guy
and a basketball person to see it it
dwarfs
any super bowl it dwarfs and this was a
regular season game this wasn't even
anything like
me like that's the difference level of
yeah it's it's nonstop but salute
for sure man yeah that i definitely hear
where you're coming from what happened
tremendous energy for sure
that's why i was like this is a good
conversation that was like something
somebody
checked kind of nailed it and was like
so i was like i was going to say
for you first time you went to the farm
how excited were you
oh that you could play soccer there yeah
it was swim with it during the
during the beta or was it the beta that
they opened the farm
uh and then is that what it was yeah
there was a time where
people were streaming and they're like
i've been in the farm for 17 hours after
the beta ended like that kind of i think
it was the farm because we thought
that's all the sort of space we were
going to have
and then we got to like the tower wall
for a while so yeah
it was cool to play soccer in there i
enjoyed it but
you can also you could also play soccer
couldn't you play soccer in the tower in
that back area
yes i don't know if you can anymore
since what's this back there yeah i
don't know yeah
i see a question i don't know if you can
still but yeah i thought that was funny
i liked what they said
the the farm soccer is about as obsolete
as the men's soccer team
that's amazing somebody was even saying
like oh like you could play destiny in
soccer i was like
i don't know if anybody else played this
damn game but mega man soccer
did anybody ever play that oh because it
was like all the different like mega man
powers and stuff like that
oh it was absolutely bonkers it was like
kind of like mario soccer and stuff so
of course like nes game but you've got
mega man with all the different like you
know wood guy and saga
like all those crazy people they're
playing soccer together and you got like
slides like
i'm probably awful at fifa and the
couple times i picked it up i'm like i
don't understand how it can be this bad
at a video game
because i am awful at fifa for the two
or three times i've ever picked up like
a demo and be like oh
i'm like oh god those games play great
though
yeah um but on the other side like mega
man soccer and like that type of stuff
those were fun it's just been a long
time yeah oh yeah okay apparently we
have stuff to talk about the world of
destiny an
hour and 15 minutes in the podcast
so we got some stuff
in the game where do you guys want to
start
because the trailer yeah that seems like
a good place to be
a good place what stood out the most
from the trailer to you guys when you
were looking through it like what
what happened during the trailer
multiple different pieces stood out the
most to you guys
oh let's go with the luke this is gonna
sound dumb
and this is me being like uh oblivious
to things once again
but uh i lit i watched it on twitter but
with the audio off
and then like later on everyone's like
the empress is gonna be there i'm like
empress what are you guys talking about
there's no empress
i think that this this this main
character i didn't know that it was a
female
which is if if that's what like there
are in cabal i don't actually know what
the genders are for cabal
but that's a it's a female yeah i was
like was i watching the wrong thing
because everyone's like the empress is
here and because and then i rewatch i'm
like oh that is
an interesting looking uh bad character
that looks kind of like an elephant
without a nose yes
yeah yes uh but i i
honestly um what stood out to me was i
saw the palindrome and i got really
excited
old contract baby gotta get those three
issues
we like every issue we like that reissue
and it's our favorite issue
and honestly um just
i didn't actually i mean i was i'm
pretty excited about this
i don't really care much for cabal so
yeah when i saw that it was cabal again
i was like oh my gosh
how many more times are we gonna be
fighting against another version of the
red
the red or whatever but that's not them
now it's the
whatever they're we're called i think i
read it somewhere they called the
the what was it it's somewhere in the
i don't know somewhere in there but she
pro i i did like think the most hardcore
part of the trailer was
when she's like bow to me and falls like
no and then and then which obviously if
he would have bowed to her i'll be like
what the heck's wrong with you or
something
it's not him i think for a second people
like is he
yeah because he's stuttered he's like
no usually
no we are guardians like he usually does
stuff like that but
i don't know it was interesting what
about you guys yeah i mean
for me it's you know i love i love it
there's nothing better than the dusty
trailers
to see where the direction is going to
go and um i was excited because um you
know i didn't
i didn't see the whole candle that's the
pronunciation over there
title yeah i didn't see that coming you
know i didn't think we would get
anything
in involving that storyline so now that
we have it
it's confirmed you know i thought she
was cool i thought she was cool
you know this pseudo negotiation that's
supposed to happen
yeah and you know it's a voice of
violence he ain't one bending me
he did not would have been indeed i
gotta respect it you know so that was
cool um
you know just see i think for me whether
we wanted it or not we've stepped into a
war with the cabal
the cosmodrome yeah everywhere
everywhere i'm saying
so that that was interested i like my
man oh in the background seeing part of
the negotiation
do you know what's going on it's pretty
quiet he was quiet
he got some stuff to say at the end
which i'll comment on but um you know
for me
the first thing that really excited me
was strikes
i didn't think we were gonna guess you
know the three so i'm like wow
that's cool we're getting a new one
which i didn't see i thought we're just
gonna get the two
baby revised and that's it so that was
cool you know i looked at the new
activity i'm like okay
not six man which i was hoping but look
unique
so i'm like all right you know cool cool
cool quarter snippet of the crow
in one of these negotiations with a bad
load no he looks
good osiris hit him up with some drips
yeah i look like some gold or syrian
drip
he's gonna have to they're gonna have to
sell that in the bungee store yeah yeah
that that drip is
woo so that was good that was cool i was
good to see him out there i want to know
where they go with that because
again i didn't think knowing bungie
there they'll do a story arc
and then they'll they'll go away from it
so i didn't know what was going to
happen we're going to see him again
right after that um you know the thing
so it's cool to see him
and then yeah man the last thing of the
trailer i will say i mean i'll see the
weapons exact they
you know they talk about all the weapon
infusion that they're putting back into
a
good trials of course you know i'm happy
i'm you know child of charles family i
love that
but um i think for me
at the end and shout out to e for
bringing to my attention
she's like yo you didn't see the import
and i'm like what you talking about and
it was like a second
and he saw that little scorn
apparently it's a yeah it's a normal
looking scream
which somebody showed me a picture later
on i thought it was like a crazy looking
screen but somebody just took like a
screenshot
but it is this is going to be my part so
i'm just going to steal your thunder
here
yeah go for it oh this is the only you
covered the trailer it's like all right
i don't want the import i'll take that
so the end of the trailer um a couple
things one
osiris is so there's a like two frames i
literally had to like go
frame by frame in the video to try and
figure out because i'm doing this live
on stream
and i'm trying to like zoom fast forward
and every time it pops i'm like i can't
pause it fast enough so i'm going
frame frame frame pause okay so it's a
picture it looks like a horror movie
shot like resident evil
picture but it's a screen and then like
the other it's like a black frame and
then one more where it's a bit closer up
and you can see the teeth and it's
definitely like it's a scream
and it's not a crazy one i thought it
was like an ogre scream because it
looked all weird but apparently they
just look like that it's just shot in a
strange way
okay and then during that darkness part
of the video oh cyrus says
osiris says there is no light in
here which somebody in my chat uh
brought to my
to reminded me that's also what zal says
in that whisper mission
that's true i totally forgot about that
that's kind of an interesting
implication of that piece
um but the other side is it shows just
like a ship now it also looks like
it's floating in the tangled shore and
stuff of that nature to be like
you can't tell if that ship's in good
shape or not because it's just kind of
floating there the bottom hanger door is
open
and then there's a little bit of writing
that shows up on screen
and my speculation and again it's like
this is my
hope i don't know what to expect let's
go
the ship floating there i think between
chat and i talking about this for the
last couple of days
we're hoping that's like a secret
mission
now like a gun like an exot like the
exotic secret you have
you have the tex mechanica redacted
quest
so we don't know if it could be related
to that it would seem weird that a hive
cabal weird ship is text
mechanic-related because those two those
two don't seem to connect
but maybe there's some weird you know
blueprint somewhere
um but there's also a piece of lore
thank you to my chat by the way because
they're like go look on this single
piece of armor
there's one line that says this and it
says there's a rumor that kallus
was going around scooping up scorn
so if you kind of put 1 and 3 and 4.5
together
you can basically potentially say maybe
there was a ball ship because it looks
like it's floating in kind of an
asteroid belt area
that's driving around the like tangled
shore trying to pick up scorn
and in my mind what i leap to and i know
this isn't going to be true but i'll
tell you another reason why i hope it is
i'm hoping this is like alien isolation
there's a ship there was
well like one of calluses like hey go
pick up these as many as you can find
the scorn get out they take over the
ship and now it's just like over
like alien isolation type thing is what
i'm picturing you gotta be kind of fired
i've been kind of fired
and then [ __ ] dungeon thank you exactly
what i'm thinking about and then the
other piece is nine hydras
is an amazing artist um shout out to her
eve
for bungie she has made like part of
zero hour
helped with shattered throne so we're
talking secret missions and dungeons
and i'm going same person said that's
the only thing you
tweeted was like which just just tweeted
about
be like that and there is no light here
that's all she tweeted from the trailer
um
all of that stuff together i'm like wow
secret mission what if it's like a time
doing where you got to go into the ship
you've got to like
get into like you know the bows of the
ship go steal this like blue
or something that's in there and then
escape within time as well i can see it
happening again this is way
too far and don't and it's everything i
say is always temper your expectations
i'm not tempering for this one because i
want to see some players
yes i'm excited about that because those
are my favorite pieces of destiny
the raids are great and deep stone crypt
really cool always in king's fall trust
me you and me agree on that raid as well
but the dungeons the solo experience
those have been my favorites
so crossing my face all i'm saying is
i'm crossing my fingers it could
literally be nothing it could be a
cinematic that goes into season 14 and
it's squat
but my hope is that i will say this to
jump in
and on the timing is about right
if it is because okay we got we got our
raid
right we know we're not most likely
going to get
vault revisited this season right so
it's going to be you figure another
season for
for that to come back and yeah it's it's
about dungeon time
it's about engine time yeah you know it
definitely is so um
i could see it you know and we looked at
that calendar which we'll get into
you know there's there's some some room
some wiggle room space that could do it
and um yeah man like shout out to the
chat
i was just oh my whole thing was like
cause you know what i'm gonna do besides
i'm like oh sorry would you stay in the
house
stay in the house bro stay back in the
time what what are you doing out there
like he still i didn't think he'd be
moving around and doing this stuff again
i'm like
this is not what i want to hear right
now i don't want to hear about you
bellowing that there's no light
in some area where you ain't supposed to
be please get back
to the bazaar at the time go sit there
go until we get you another ghost
exactly we're gonna find this
on the cigarettes she still exists so
get something we gonna work it out but
that was my whole thing but not all
jokes aside
i do hope um it is a dungeon that would
be cool
and um yeah and the last thing i'll say
was um
no leviathan no leviathan so i was
interested you know i'm very curious to
see
what has happened i wanna i'm curious to
see kadle
and the callous relationship if that
gets touched on even more
during the conversations we have with
her but the vibe i'm getting i don't
want
i mean i don't know if you felt really
just luke that even though
we didn't agree to her terms if you look
at the thing it's almost like we have to
prove our worth to her in cabal
turn like the way they respect each
other it's like through strength
right so it's like okay we do this we
beat her champions we do this
then it's like okay i'll align with you
because as in the cabal way
you have earned it kind of thing what do
you get from that
yeah i feel like and if i'm predicting
what's going to happen
and predict i'm predicting that it's
going to twist so like she said
you need to bow to me and it and what
they do need
to work together everyone has worked
together to defeat the darkness
but it has to be the other way it has to
be on the good side of things it can't
be like
a dictatorship or the cabal or leading
everything it's got to be like a two-way
streak so i think you're right
we're gonna like prove ourselves to her
i don't think that she's going to be
someone we kill i think it's going to be
like
we get to a point where she respects us
and she's
like does the hand you know it's just at
the end like you know what buddy
oh it's a little tiny guardian hand and
then
uh it's like i'll see you on the grid
fist bump yeah and then somehow
the cabal or maybe on our side or like
maybe this is all leading up to because
i think this is all leading up to
lightfall which is gonna be
you know lots of aligning of teams and
a big army because last time yeah
because last time it didn't work very
well when it was just the humans
and the guardians fighting it needs to
be everyone fighting for the system
so i think this is just a start to that
also
and before i i forget this imagine how
funny it would have been
if kade was so alive and he was in that
room whenever she was saying bow to me
oh god what would have been his little
one like
one liner would be lit
that's kind of what i feel like and i
just thought i didn't think about that
until just now like
that is probably the route it's going
and that's like a good i want my mind to
keep thinking that because i need the
storyline to keep going because
it kind of stinks at the beginning of
beyond light like the darkness came and
then that big
light happened and then we lost part of
the system and then we didn't talk about
it much more after that like the next
day beyond light just came out i'm like
this is crazy did everyone just die like
the whole
place blew up but it i mean so i want
that storyline to keep happening and
obviously it's going to because they
have cut scenes that are literally them
saying the darkness is here and we are
surrounded by it and
you must bow us but of course the cabal
is going to make it a little bit tougher
for us to figure out how to make that
happen we have to
prove our worth and do a season of stuff
or what do you think why do you guys
think and this might be off why do you
guys think it's called season of the
chosen
that's a good question that's a good
question oh what do you think
i mean i'm a little confused because
the callous storyline to me
felt like you know we were aligning and
doing
things for him we don't say like we were
setting up when we we have a
relationship with kallus right
we know the story with the whole
midnight cool which i think is an
awesome story you know what i'm saying
which is you know kadle and the powers
that be
you know what dominance goal overthrew
she over the whole father
you know so this is interesting i mean
that
you know does she know we're working
with alice you know i said
like it that this dynamic with callus is
very interesting
i'm i'm dying to know one about kalas
what's his plan what's his overall goal
the relationship the leviathan that
whole thing but
to your point you know narratively
there's a lot of questions here because
it does
feel like we are going to align with her
you know what i'm saying and it does
feel that it's it's almost like
like like luke say like you know it
feels like let's be real we did beyond
light
barracks and those fallen that are not
we're on the side of aramis
they're leaning towards the light right
you got the
remaining cabal let's be real very
fractured so
let's be real first she ain't got no
reason pulling up on nobody talking
about bombing
anybody i mean i love the meme that is
rolling you're going to be like
i'm sorry what have we done we've killed
gods all of this we've been kicking the
crap out of the cabal what are you
thinking like someone killed me
who are you to come to anyone demanding
anything afraid to whip you for the
flash for
expansion like stop it but i just had to
get that off
but anyway the whole thing is it's like
you see this brewing as far as another
ally so it seems like you know cabal
fallen guardians you're on the side of
life yeah i'm just i'm
and the obvious you see hive has you
know is with the darkness
it's just interesting to see how the
teams are shaping up and the matchups
and stuff like that
but i'm coming back to you and i'm like
what what do you guys think like
as far as what's what's coming i mean
you got season of the chosen
and it's like does it mean yeah what
does that imply and it's like
part of it is just the implication of
you see kaitlyn
and like zavala and osiris and then you
see a piece of that cutscene later where
they're standing over like a scion stand
in front of a chest and they're talking
and crows behind zavala
crow gets an upgrade if he's standing
next to zavala by the way so i'm very
curious how the hell that pans out
that's true yeah that cop is that yeah
but again she's like she was always like
i'll get my gilded knife and i'll see
you on the battlefield like
it's almost more of like a competition
who's gonna come out on top
yes because even when like she steps
back and you see the sights get drawn on
the two
yeah on the two main like uh zavaland
osiris
it's not like i'm going to kill you it's
like you i want to see
it's like bow to me and zavala is like
no so it's like okay we have different
ideas
she's a military leader right but it's
like
the bigger evil like is you know is the
end of me
my enemy my friend that's the point of
all so she's like
bow now okay they're not gonna bow all
right let's see what they're made of and
i think this is going to be the season
of
you know either chosen is a weird word
to try and yeah so it's like i don't
know how i can specifically tie that
together
but for me it does seem like
battlegrounds are literally what this
season's thing they're called
right our champions versus their
champions going head-to-head
in the gridiron to see who's going to
basically come out on top
and i think if we kick the crap out of
them enough which we know we're going to
do because we're going to beat the cabal
all the time
i feel like she almost has to and i
don't know how callous is gonna come
into play
but the cabal i don't know where the
fallen falls still haven't figured out
where they're gonna fall but i think the
cabal
are hopefully gonna be smart enough in
the long run because cows did the same
thing he put us through games he tested
us
he put us through all about respect like
that's how he has
it's like so ideology yeah so the war
yeah as you said like the warriors if
you can win in
you know the gladiator games if you come
out on top i'm going to respect you and
then we can work together but we have
exactly so this is kind of like the
battleground
proving grounds per se yes i still don't
know why chosen specifically is there
whether like bro has a specific story to
be like
chosen for him or i don't know i don't
know where the chosen comes in but i
definitely will say like
i think we one way or another callus
kaitlyn both
none some ally with cabal to go against
the darkness
like because she's like these are the
two right we got to do this together
to hold a shot so it's like i think it
eventually has to get there
yeah last point let me go on with this
long it's just maybe
in cabal terms them seeing
us as the chosen i don't know i'm just
it's a very interesting term to make it
season of the chosen so
i'm curious to see where they go insane
um
so we got that you mentioned the strikes
so we get the two old ones
um from d1 which are going to be new to
some people
uh so you've got sepiks in the devil's
lair and you've got the fallen saber
strike
all i can say is the warsat
protection on a grand master nightfall
good freaking luck dude
yeah so i know that's going to be dicey
sepiks
i mean you can figure out that one will
be a bit more manageable i'm sure
there's champions of course
i just need to hear his music
that's the thing perfected music
when i got the rock remix and
sadly i don't think that would be there
i don't think they'll go i don't think
we'll get it
or i would love it if they would
occasionally just like
when you go into the strike you don't
know which track you get i would love it
if you could have both
that's true and they have to figure out
a way to tell us like that like they did
with
the uh like the omnigul remake yeah they
have to figure out a way to make it make
sense in the lore like right they've
killed this dude twice so who's the
third
one-eyed man who's gonna be in there
exalted servant
that sustains the fallen house of devils
in the cosmodrome now who is the house
of
devils is that eris or aramis is that
i can't remember him no hers was the
house of darkness
but the devil's was skolaz is that right
like that one seems kind of arbitrary
like out of nowhere so again i do hope
they get the
little bit of lore to explain why it's
there but we got a third news strike and
i'm with you cog
i did not see it coming i didn't make it
there's a big like a big giant mobile
tank on nessus that we're gonna like
kind of has a pretty cool like not quite
wrath of machine and like
zamboni vibe but definitely something
where
we're jumping around on this tank it's
pretty big i think it like it could be a
lot of fun
and it's just if nothing else like we're
going from seven up to ten strikes so
the strike pool will be cool now granted
i can sit there and say i wish they
still could
mess with some of the strike modifiers a
little more than they do but at least we
got three
but for some people be like i've seen
this strike for three years it's been a
while since i've seen it no no it's like
i was like so it will feel a little
better but for some it's like i got
one for like an entire year is what some
people are gonna see
so i mean overall i'm very curious to
see how they handle the lore piece
and i think for me that's where destiny
has me the most at this point
is the story i want to see where this
story goes because
they've been building it for so long and
we finally think they have like a
narrative like
through line and art to go through these
things and the story is what has me the
most excited
and the activities are just kind of like
the almost the journey along the way
until something just blows me away
to push it through yeah that's how i
look at it yourself
yeah i really like these those two
strikes are the two ones are beloved
sorry for the
thing but um proven grounds i can't wait
to see two yeah
i i'm excited just to get the cosmodrome
used more
because i love it and it i'm glad it
came back but there's just not
a ton of stuff to do there uh and it'd
be cool for them to not only give us
older stuff yes but
if if they could continue to figure out
how to waste figure out ways to add on
to the cosmodrome kind of like how they
do with the edz they've
added all kinds of random like little oh
yeah nooks and crannies in there where
you can
go where they just like like the mission
like all that stuff wasn't there before
so i feel like they could totally do
that with the cosmic drone just because
it's a cool spot
i love strikes i'm not not been i've
been very vocal about it but i've not
been a huge fan of strikes in d2 i don't
i don't know they just don't hit the
mark for me
i don't know if they never will because
like this is like a
i feel like it's like a syndrome that d1
players have like
nothing probably will ever be yeah i
know we always compare it to what it was
when it first started and when
something is the when you experience it
the first time it's tough to make
something better than that but i'm very
excited about
devil's lair i don't i didn't really
like the fallen saber strike a ton
it's a tougher one but not it's i don't
know but the new one does anyone come
out
on the day that this comes out or does
it come out later i'm looking at it
six to seven weeks later depending on if
you own the season pass
okay because i'm looking at the thing
and i couldn't find out is it all
proving ground strikes yeah march 23rd
okay so i'm very excited about a new
strike i wish that they would do that
more
the only thing the only thing which
we'll probably talk about a little bit
is
i hate that i don't see a new crucible
map on this again
so we can broach that right now if you
want to because
that's about as good of a transition as
we're going to get into that wonderful
topic
how does one of like they're like people
can say hype this that the other thing
the one underlying thing is people like
cool cool cool
zero i mean you've got trials trials is
the thing that they do
they've got weapons one of which is very
ironic you've got the armor which looks
fire you've got some cosmetics they talk
about that stuff
but general crucible stuff maps modes
reworks
zero zero so i just a bunch of iron
banner with when that sunk it yes i know
they actually put iron banner on there
multiple times they hadn't done that in
a while to be like iron banner and
banner and banner like this is what
you're going to be doing
they need a couple of accounts we're
going to cover the calendar a little bit
later
but just the general feeling of when it
sinks in when pvp is like
not a big focus here and then the twab
came
still mostly just trials where do you
guys sit and
cog i'm gonna give it to you first just
cause what are you what are you feeling
got my crucible shirt on today
you're like right here you don't just
try to hold out hope here
um yeah i mean look you know it
definitely
is concerning that there was not one
mention of a crucible new crucible map
you know it definitely was concerning
there was no mention of a crucible mode
trials armor looks fire let's get that
out the way
trials weapons look fire
got to give it out you know i'm saying i
i've seen that messenger in there
you know um that that looks like it's
going to be uh in the cold denial class
and right now
if you're not like cold denial and if
you gotta what is it um the no time to
explain
i'm wrecking in pvp with that like don't
try to explain i feel like i feel bad
for people who don't have it
it's really strong it's so good it is so
good
so for the messenger to be in that
archetype
incentive reward get in there
we got to see what and they said new
trials weapons
armor and more i'm holding out hope for
what the hell is i
add more let's see what is more what is
bull
right the hand cannon look fire you know
what i'm saying i ain't gonna front it
looks like the design
new ships new um
syrian what's what's the other one you
just skipped over one of the weapons
what what'd you skip
the oh ironic trials edition that you've
ever seen in your life you can
three-peak with it
yeah sure you know we gotta fix the
issues yeah that was that was the best
thing i gotta i gotta
interrupt because that was the best
thing being like oh bungie said oh you
guys wanted
swords you guys said something about
swords and trials here's the sword
like timing couldn't have been any worse
but remember as we know
they've developed in twos or whatever i
know it was cosmetics
stuff was already done yeah yeah it was
they knew that
this was they fell into this joke you
know they fell right into it
we get it it's a bad look to introduce a
sword with three peak against
what it is but at this point they're not
gonna retract what was already
in production already you know say the
vibe up this is how i'm looking at it
yes it doesn't look like i'm gonna be
real we probably we're gonna get a
sandbox update
at the end of the season you don't think
we're going to get you're almost right
you don't think we're going to get any
type of sam i think we can listen
to our sandbox update right yeah you
might be right you might be right
absolutely
we get the sandbox update at the start
of the season we don't even have it yet
we never have it yet hopefully a little
slight sandbox
the only thing they're going to do in
the middle is the titan i feel right
we know it and then yeah and are blessed
we know all the lessons gonna get
touched at some point right
but look the vibe i'm getting this is
the trials fix season
you know crucible the pure crucible what
we really miss what we really need
i think has to be addressed by next
season i just think logistically as much
as no one wants to hear it
and i didn't want to hear it you know
saying i'm sad that crucible is the way
it is
you know but the reality is i think that
it's the next season when they
actually can apply the feedback that
we've been complaining about
for so long and that's what i'm holding
out hopefully what you think look i mean
you know i don't know how big you are
with the pvp situation you know where
yeah
yeah i love to i'm i'm the kind of guy
that i go
i will level up as hard as i can and get
to max power at the beginning of a
season and then pvp is what keeps me
around at the end
like i have my flawless title i have
mine broken so i've spent my time
in the competitive scene so the thing
that kind of stinks is like this little
three month span where i haven't been
able to game as much
has kind of like i'm also like please
don't judge me i'm a controller player
on pc
no are you as well
[Music]
it stinks they at so i'm like a sniper
sniper man i love sniping
and like in between last season this
season they took a little bit of that
aim assist away and my
shot has been so off and i haven't had
enough time to like practice to get it
back to where it was
so uh and just i don't know every
sandbox switch up kind of like messes
with me a little bit
uh like i'm using i've been using the uh
i can't i
sound bad i don't ever remember the
what's the iron banner uh hand cannon
that hits like a truck
what is that archetype again is that one
that's one twenty one
twenty one twenty's okay right now 120s
are good and i've been using that and
it's been great but
i'm always i love playing pvp and it's i
really want it to get more competitive
but also
want it to be refreshed so yes it every
season that it's not refreshed in any
way and by refresh i mean like i'm as
simple i'm a cod
boy so like give me a new map and i'm
that's refreshed to me
that's all i need or an old map that was
good
that or just acknowledge that cheating
is rampant or this or that like there's
just
those are the kind of things that i
love but i also my friend uh matt
one of my friends maddox i don't know if
you guys know maddox he's a streamer
that does community scrims
like a really positive like not not as
much like the face it like super
sweaty scrims but just more like he has
his community come in and do stuff
that's been like the most refreshing
thing for me pvp wise like being able to
take it into your own hands and be like
all right we're only going to use these
guns
with this thing and this and that's been
pretty fun but like
that can only last for so stinking
i want rift back or just like something
like that that or not like the gilded uh
seals is kind of cool but i feel like
they missed the mark on that because
it goes away after a season yeah you
should tell we got cloud players we got
a good joke one
so i i don't know i'm i'm i'm in like
the feeling of
uh it needs to change very soon because
i'm so sick of playing against the same
like 20 people because
the player pool is like really small
right now and the competitive side of
things i still think if in quick play
it's fine but
yeah i like the competitive part i'm not
the most competitive person in the world
but i do like a good
like exhilarating battle where it's not
just like a streamer that streams all
day and is like
3.0 kd playing against me because i'm
not that good like i'm you're a 3.0 kd
you're
well maybe if you're 5.0 you're cheating
yeah
yes yeah 100 uh accuracy but
yeah i don't know i would just like
something like i'm pumped about these
weapons and trials because that's going
to get me back because once i
once they stopped adding new stuff i was
like yeah there's no point in it
i was like it's doing new stuff i agree
yeah
the new stuff was coming so i was like
it didn't make any sense
kind of predicted that this season would
be the new stuff yeah and that's not
going to hit my head
it's not going to last that long exactly
but if i get the new hotness didn't do
that i mean
i want you to look like my thing is it's
sad because
it's just sad because when i do my
pinnacles
or i'm in there i'm having fun
and comps you know i'm having fun too
ever since
iron banner solo queue and comp solo
queue are a thing
when i am in there i'm having a good
time i'm really
am i'm i'm saying it's fun it's like i
want a reason to still be
in here you know what i mean and that
it's just finding that motivation it's
just not there so
now we we will get to it you know with
the whole um whatever they're adding we
see what they're adding
and as far as the weapons and stuff like
that but you know
i'm at this point i'm just even hoping
for since they're not doing no
major change right now with playing core
crucible
can we at least get the rewards from
like uh can we get some golf balls for
the for the
for the valentine's day okay can we can
we get some presents
can we get those modules yeah shout out
to ascendant nomad i mean he did his
whole
crucible rework video and he's just like
you can cop you can take everything
i don't care but it's like that's one of
those things i think
the glory playlist needs reworked into
and i know a lot of people have said
it but it's like i haven't played
starcraft on pc and i
sucked at it by the way i was never very
good but you stole your ladder system
your number rank your tier your silver
gold platinum bronze diamond whatever
and you it gave you something to strive
for it be like i'm in here
maybe at least for me if i could ever
play enough to get decent enough to get
to gold
i know there's like crazy people above
me but if i can get to like if i can go
up a tier i'm gonna feel like i improved
that's one of those things that crucible
and that grind has not had i mean you
already said the guilded seal is like
unbroken like really you're gonna go for
that again
yeah no but uh that wasn't fun the first
time it wasn't
the first time but like that's the piece
to where it's like for somebody like me
i'm never gonna claim to be like
there are people who destroy me in pvp
all day long get it but i'm always kind
of like okay
and that would be that would be a way
for me and my head to go
is it a good match is it a bad match i
have my i always have like i always have
the matches that i feel like i'm on a
roller coaster if i play a lot like
i just got destroyed and got my crap
pushed in and on the other side i'm like
i'm over here and i'm like i just
destroyed them how did those two games
happen
back to back and if there was some
consistency in like the skill level i'm
playing against
and that my skill was slowly creeping
upward it would at least show that i'm
doing something
right and that's where i think quickplay
can have it's like
fun yes no maybe i sucked i killed
everybody that's gonna happen in there
we get that and like fun game modes too
but some type of like ranked ladder
system and i'm not the first person to
say it by any means
would give and again put also decent
rewards in there as you level up you
know get certain things
but it's like that is that is what's
going to give people on a competitive
side
something because if you're not going to
get rid of it which some people like get
in a crucible get rid of stasis
by the way i'm going to tell everybody
now stasis is not going anywhere they
put too much money into it they're not
just going to turn it off
yeah it's on the map it's sort of a sort
of road map for you know
aspects or whatever yeah new aspect
coming so it's not going anywhere so
it's like
now it's like for them balancing it
trying to do things to it that's one
thing
but it's not going anywhere but yeah
some some reason to go in there would be
nice
yeah i think people have way over
like gone way overboard with the anger
with stasis
i keep saying this it's a new the other
ones have been around for seven years
like some of them have been around for
seven years of
balancing this is the first season that
this was in here
like we all should have known that it
was gonna be broken in some sort of way
it's freezing there's always stuff
broken in other games
with freezing somebody so i think that
this season they're going to be
tinkering with it a lot more
oh yeah they were in the past which is
good and i want i just want to encourage
people that are
if anyone's ever listening to this and
you're getting shattered
it'll get better i promise
maybe i promise i'm just kidding i can't
promise things i'm not making it but
i do i i do agree with you with the
so like the only like when i play
crucible
i don't play super i feel like i play
really good whenever there's like
a motivation there like unbroken seal
for three seasons i was motivated to get
to 5500
whenever recluse was available at like
getting to 2200 or whatever
i was like i'm gonna play my best i'm
gonna practice all the time
now it's like when i go play comp it's
like unless you're like carrying someone
or trying to help someone gets 5500
there's like
it's kind of competitive but it's also
kind of like my when my motivation goes
away
my skill level goes down i don't know
why that is and that's how
that's how crucial has been for me all
season and last season other than like
when i was trying to get the flawless
seal
it's like ugh this is fun i'll play like
three comp matches and i'm like barely
paying attention i'm like reading my
chat i'm not like
you don't have and the i feel like
what you said about it's like doing a
it's like comp like comps like a good
groundwork for it but like some sort of
actual ranking system which has been
talked about so much by so many people
like
some sort of rank like something from
like look at overwatch or like there's
like so many different options
that would just bring motivation even
even loot yeah loot is good motivation
but if there's something even deeper
that motivates people on a competitive
level because competitive people don't
care as much about loot
as much as they care about being like
i'm better than that other person
because i beat them and it shows for it
on this ranking system you know what i
mean
uh which would event also make it i've
always thought it would be cool and it
makes it it's very difficult for destiny
to be like
a competitive like esports game because
of
like the the sandbox and the way that
weapons change
but it would be so cool if there was
some sort of way to make it
on that level not just because it's cool
but also because i would love for more
people's eyes to be on it because it's
such a
good feeling game even even no matter
where crucible's at playing pvp is fun
like as much as people say it's easy
like i get it a lot of people are
ballers at this game i'm not like the
most insane baller it
i i think it's it takes skill even
though the hitbox is big
it still takes skill that you have to
hit people in the head like in call of
duty the
the time to kill so fast you can shoot
him in the stomach and die
and destiny if you shoot him with
someone in the stomach you're gonna get
killed because they're gonna tap you in
the head three times
i've always appreciated that like when i
first started playing crucible i was
like
uh this is not very easy i have to hit
them in the head like
i was not conditioned to only shoot at
the head condition
i gotta shoot wherever the person is
maybe that's just the player that i am
but
it's a fun it feels good the gunplay is
good so if they could just add like just
a few little things they got everything
else there
yeah and then it would make the
community feel like they're being
listened to i think that's the biggest
problem is the people that
community feels like they're in the dark
they feel like why don't you care about
us
obviously there's less of us than the pv
community but come on
just no i agree i agree but i i think
it's
you know to add on shout out to the dab
shout out to justin
but um yeah man it's just like i i
listen they know
that at this point it's a meme you know
we're listening like
they know what's going on it cannot be
that they are
in my opinion i'm at the point now i'm
like all right
it has been neglected so much now it
cannot be a situation where they have
not hurt us and they just try to
get through the day and not listen
it can't be that so it's got to be
someone and that's why i'm hoping when
we hear from my mans what's our man's
name
she's coming blackburn blackburn when
we're here from the blackburn you know
what i'm saying hopefully you haven't
heard from luke in a bit
i need to hear from you i think it's
gonna be joe not luke this time that's
why probably joe this time okay so
luke's doing what luke do
but joe when he dropped the state of the
union
i need to know logistically
what's the issue why is the hold up that
we
know the community wants this they know
it we know it
it's got to be coming but the reasoning
why
has to be explained and that's what i'm
holding firm for
but for this season it's not it let's
just call it what it is there's no new
maps
trials though should get a resurgence
and i'm curious to see
how the um the cheating aspect is also
addressed as well
for pc as well and um again i think this
is a cool
for trial at least to get that a little
shot in the arm for that i'm going to go
into trials this season
but there's motivation now i i that i i
just was not doing it this will hesitate
at all
there was no motivation and beyond light
at all but now
i'm looking for it man we'll see we'll
see so that's that's my mindset
with the whole crucible thing
yeah um i mean honestly like
the armor alone i was even saying to
aries in chat
um somebody said it's something
they might have been dcp i was listening
to last night just it looks
mean and i love it yeah
dude the eye holes on the titan are just
like that like
dude i will say like if i'm ever going
to go after a set of armor that titan
armor
probably one of the most fire i've seen
for me in a while
yeah you know what he is like the titans
helmet really looks like this though
he's like right yeah
it's not a giant he doesn't have like
wings
or a satellite on his head
like he doesn't have like a giant shield
everything looks
like clean tight angry and i'm gonna
kick your ass like
now all of them do like the warlock is
probably the most minimal
of the three but still looks damn good
but i would say the hunter and the titan
hunter the titan got it just yeah you
got it it's five
so and of course if you know the
summoner's a pulse rifle that pulses are
my thing so see if i can
yeah might be might be asking for some
backpack help at some point because i'm
definitely not gonna holla at me
yeah let's see that's the backpack let's
all three play trials together next
season
i'm gonna be going for that bounty need
that bounty yeah
like trials is our new kinetic grenade
launcher friend
maybe kinetic we don't know but we are
getting a breach load grenade launcher
salvager salvo which say that 10 times
fast
uh that is our pursuit weapon for the
season now it looks
a lot like like mountaintop
it looks like a mountaintop hopefully
there's no macro missile
perk they will not put that back again
oh man
what's up what's it look what's it i
want it for
pve not pvp
but like i like recluse in
yeah what did you guys think of that one
just any like they have to see it when
you when we see it don't know what the
perk is just kind of like
if nothing else it does look like a
kinetic and as we lost all of the
options
i want it to be connected so we just
have one of those because malicious
birthright and mountaintop are both gone
so if you do want to just like go energy
and kinetic grenade launcher it'll just
be nice to have one so i'm hoping that
is outside of the pert i won't know till
i see it
i think it's going to be cool i really
like my uh
i'm trying to remember the name of it
this is i probably don't like it as much
as i can remember the name of it uh
it's oh here we go my wither horde um
i really like the weather horde and if
i'm going to use a kinetic
um you know grenade launcher i'm usually
going to use that because it's just nice
and pve
to have like the i used it a lot at the
beginning of the season actually because
you get those little pools and it just
felt really powerful it was so powerful
they got rid of they turned it off for a
while
in pvp and every once in a while i
really like to have
just because i used mountaintop so much
of foreign pve i would like to have a
really good
alternative to that so that's not like
over overload and pvp kind of thing so i
hope that it's good i get excited seeing
grenade launchers just because
i like i like using i like using them in
pve
that's it i don't like to use them in
pvp obviously like i'm not because i
know some people who will be in pvp with
fighting lions just destroying
destroying
i don't do amazing but if i i've like
after the um
what was the what was the grind it what
was it
right it was it mountaintop was that the
crazy one yeah i was like yeah just that
was the thing they had to use all the
grenade launchers but like you also had
to get heavy kills as well and those
were kind of annoying
um but now going through that training
for mountaintop which is why i kind of
miss those style of quests
dude my skills with like breach load
so far improved like fighting lion
having
the ability to do the damage it does
being primary ammo so i'm literally just
running around with that constantly
then decent weapon working on bounces
angles timings like
it was it's not the most efficient but
it is a
fun way to play to try and be like hey
lob it oh cool i got the right explosion
bam that like you know it just it's fun
to mess around with so
i hope people don't get to where they
like abuse it with the new changes for
like you can hold it down and if you hit
them it's
you know it's going to be the direct hit
i think people worried like
you could bounce it and it just does all
the things and still connects you don't
have to worry about the timing because
that is part of it the skill
of the hold it down figure out the time
like if i'm going to bounce it off a
doorway and go
try and catch somebody waiting on the
other side i got to make sure i time it
right not bounce it
oh i hit him in the face cool like so
i'm hoping the skill is still there but
i
i
goofily had a fair amount of fun getting
into that one and that's as you said too
is like
give me something to grind i miss those
crucible quests that you could only get
in there that i had to work on a certain
thing i had to be a comp for that and it
was like and it would force you to play
a different playstyle and teach you
stuff and i missed that stuff
i missed that i do i miss pinnacle
weapons so badly i mean
for all those reasons you said and um
yeah i mean
you know to get back on point with the
breach load i would look like i do
like you know that it's coming back and
hopefully you know we'll see if it's
kinetic
i'm with chat they're like there's no
way they're gonna make
any type of mountain top perk on their
stick
this this thing will act behave
differently yes
there was a reason there's another
reason why sun said it existed to stop
some of the op weapons that they
themselves made they went the course
correct so that's what i feel is going
on here you know it'll probably have
some type of
maybe unique perk or role you know that
you can get from it
and then um it looks like they go on the
route again with like how they went with
adorned with each mold gives you a
different skin
or whatever gambit crucible and vanguard
stuff like that
you know it'll definitely be different
but yeah i'm with you i think um
you know we definitely we we got to get
the pinnacles man
we got to get them back we need them
that that that's
the grind we're looking for to get back
in those bowls yes
i remember staying in gambit all day for
a breakneck
i remember you know in the um what what
was the heavy in gambit that was
that had overflow what was that heavy
was oh um
21 percent delirium you know what i'm
saying like you know you remember yo
grinding for that recluse and you know
regardless to what they
got to the even if they don't want to
put
so op perks the concept of having these
unique weapons
live in these specific modes and you
know it encourages the grind
it encourages it you know i mean so you
got to put that back in there
and don't know like i mean i like this
whole thing with breach load
but i mean with salvage or salvo but if
we still need a little bit more we still
need the pedicles got to come back yeah
where's the crap where's the stuff that
craps on everything else we had that
quote last
last week as well yeah they sunseted so
that we could have more stuff
new stuff that craps on everything else
and they didn't give that to us yet
exactly which is a whole conversation
about
why sunsetting happened too early kind
of thing but yeah
i don't know that's just my opinion i
missed pinnacles pinnacle weapons were
like
that's why i'm gonna play a season i'm
gonna get this pinnacle weapon
facts and i loved it that was so fun to
do and some of my favorite weapons were
pinnacles like when to go that was one
of my go-to guns to use in
pve just because it had a unique perk
that you
had to grind to get that makes sense to
do that and if you want to make it not
over powerful just make it useful for
two seasons and then get rid of it like
that's what some said it should be for
right
like so they shouldn't panic like two
seasons and then it's gonna go
like i remember when i got um
loaded question i was like yo this is
very underrated
that explosion rate i was like man like
again they got the sun setting exists so
that this doesn't last that long anyway
so just bring it back let's do it
let's do it man i'm with you as for the
idea of sun setting we also have the
other side of that coin reissues some of
these are from d1 the swarm paladin
shadow price
so these are all going to be coming from
the nightfalls
um and we've got swarm
machine gun palindrome which is the one
most people are favoring towards is
going to be the hand cannon
do you guys think it'll be a 120 or a
140.
um i don't know
palindrome it looks like the midnight
coupe but i don't know if it'll be like
the same
i don't know i want to say 140 but
i'm going for it what you hold on what's
the trials hand cannon
um that thing looks sweet
man i don't know man
what would they have the balls to make
it a 150
[Music]
would they have the balls to truly make
it unique and make a morphing like what
is it sunshine
they got sunshine
that would be interesting i think
that'll retain its
exotic nature with the 150 would be my
guess
but based on the the architectural style
of the gun
it doesn't look heavy enough to be a 120
right
so to me it still screams 140 or maybe
even 180. you know saying
who knows you know saying it it looks
kind of
like loose or lighter if it's a 180 i'm
not using it
well 180 we know it yeah well i'm
already terrible with them some people
might like him but i'm just terrible
and then we've got shadow price that's
the auto rifle anybody i know that's
like deja's gun
yeah that was always his do you guys do
you guys have anybody who's like shadow
price like
a boy from um the destiny show podcast
like his whole cornhole he's yeah you
know shout out shadow price his biggest
shadow price
is that's his favorite auto of all time
so i know he's going crazy but what do
you think luke
i think that when i see shadow price i
just think of that's just like og
you know what i mean like that is like a
gun that represents
destiny for some reason i don't know why
i didn't use it much to be honest
but i feel like i've seen it so often
in d1 and i don't know why but you know
it kind of looks like the gun that some
of the little robots were carrying in
in one way or another i don't know
something like the little ai i feel like
they've had shadow price before
um i don't i don't use auto rifles often
like
i think gnawing hunger is the one i've
used the most and uh
it's a hard light whenever it was op
that one season when trials came out oh
my gosh
so much because of that uh
we'll be sick if it was kind of like uh
oh shoot what was that gun what was the
auto rifle the
the really op auto rifle from trials in
d1 doctrine passing
what if it was like that for some reason
they just make it definitely not going
to be the same gun because it was never
that fast
yeah i know but but yeah
auto rifle
yeah yeah that could be it man we gotta
the swarm's coming i'm i'm pumped to
have another like there's not that many
weapons like that in that archetype
anymore ever since they did sunsetting
sunsetting broke a couple machine guns
was one bose is another
where you're truly missing like
damage types for some of these weapons
like there's not a void bow
period yeah yeah yeah same thing with
machine guns i feel like that's gone too
so it's like we're missing certain
pieces and not all of them can be exotic
so i agree
about all of that um going back to
season the chosen because we
seem to be jumping around this whole
thing um speaking of weapons though
the uh solar bow now i have no idea how
to say this
i'm calling it tiku's divination i know
i can say the word divination but
t-i-c-u-u
how did you guys say that luke
where is that typed at it is that in the
twab i can put it in chat if that helps
you
i don't know i actually must have missed
that is that the exotic bow
eyes of tomorrow it's like the eyes of
tomorrow
bow basically uh i don't i don't know
how to say it because i
honestly saw it in the trailer and i was
like oh but i don't care so then i just
was like that's the same thing okay
that's for them
i'm just now getting into leviathan's
breath for nightfalls
but um look i wanted to give it a shot
you know what i'm saying i'm just
you know tycoo somebody's saying okay
that would make sense so it's spelled
t-o-c-u-u
no i just don't care about i i want more
exotic snipers to be honest with you
i feel like we haven't got anything yeah
it's been a minute yeah
wow yeah oh i guess where to go with the
text mechanic request wait a minute we
got one
we got cloud strength we got clowns
right so i'm over here
yeah no i was like believe me that gun
is amazing that's why
stuff like the whole you're so squeezed
into certain weapons for a certain mods
thing
if we could use some just like if you
could have an unstoppable
a and you could pick what it is not
here's your lane for this season i was
like do you have to wait a year just use
a bow in a lost sector pisses me off
sometimes because like
there's only so many primaries it's like
and i miss bows because
they're like they're precise and they
hit hard but
like you got the draw time and
everything the exotics are cool you can
have fun with those and now the exotics
you could finally pair with the mods as
well because they're on armor
so i really am hoping for like some bow
fun and
with an exotic bow it better be in the
uh artifact mods but we'll see
yes but this one i broke it down like
frame by frame you see the arrows go
and fire and that goes it goes out as
three you can literally watch them like
curve out and turn to the other two
targets while the other one's still
traveling
first guy gets his little explosion shot
and there's like a cup like literally a
pixel wide of two arrows going sideways
and then like a little wider left guy
gets hit first and the right guy gets
hit
last so it goes so it literally goes
down first split split
but it like goes down and splits so it
can track three targets at once
um i don't know i'm just kind of excited
because bows are fun
now i have no idea how good it would
actually be
and how precision shots are gonna work
right but i'm wondering like can you
precision shot a guardian in the head
and how accurate is to the other two
right so i like i imagine it's probably
not three tap
yeah if you can get three and then you
just like boom and you just like
finish them up after you get three head
shots i'm just like that could be
that could be fun it could be yeah he's
a
potential there's definitely some
potential yet listen really give it a
shot of course
i'll get it and i'll use it for a few
minutes and then i'll
take it off and put it in the vault well
for me i'm gonna use this a lot more
than i will duality i will tell you that
though oh yeah i haven't even used that
once if i'm being honest with you guys i
put it in there and put it right in the
vault it was actually very good it was
actually once i learned how to use it
properly because i
i wasn't procking the perk i was using
precision shots at the beginning you're
supposed to shoot from the hip
to to unlock and once you stack that
what is it black wings whatever it is it
hits like a truck like you you can
start taking down bosses and stuff so
it's pretty much like clean up cleaning
cleanup charge it up and then precision
shot bang superpower and then pvp
criminally underrated very good crazy
range
very good it's actually very good i was
surprised how good it was but in the
beginning
it took a little while to get adjusted
too yeah yeah
yeah so we got that tease we have the
exotic quest redacted it's sex mechanic
i don't know what it is
some people are like oh bring back the
first curse please for the love of god
no
it's a kinetic hand cannon we have too
many hand cannons in the first place
give us another archetype somebody said
sniper i'd be like cool
smg could also do that i don't really
care but if it's another handgun and a
rifle
or anything else is all that's
awake we have so
many that is true no they have like
iconic stories but
like some people said the first curse
i'm like please no just no i don't want
it no
too too soon what if they somehow come
out with a new gun
that hasn't come out before wouldn't
that be something no
it's not a re-issue we haven't seen it
even if it's new and it's a hand cannon
he's gonna be
i would be happier if it was new and it
was a hand cannon the first curse but i
still don't want to hand we just got
hawkmoon
which is one of the reasons why like i
swear to god if it's a kinetic hand
cannon i'm gonna lose my mind and the
reason i say kinetic
everything text mechanica is chaperone
last word they're all kinetic they don't
have an energy type i think they're
truly about like
you know bullets basically they're not
about energies
it could be first curse yo
you're gonna like witness me explode
over here if it's first curse i'm just
gonna be mad
and let me tell you 120 i it's
definitely a 120.
somebody said somebody said rumored like
sawed off shotgun
i could see that being kind of unique
and interesting which would be
something that's talking about the range
stat is literally like
one you have to be hugging that person
and it's in their stomach and then you
pull the trigger that's the only way you
can kill them
give us a heavy hand cannon yeah a heavy
head
what
it takes two people to fire it because
it's so big
[Laughter]
i've done i have done yeah man
listen oh i guess that's true yeah
prospector is art that's true
yeah it could be an energy i never
thought about that actually so yeah it
could be energy
good to see we got to see so
redacted quest don't know where that's
at got the bow uh the
the weapons the spiral weapons the gold
or
ones with the spiral shape on them some
of my chat was saying those look like
reissues of leviathan weapons i wonder
what you guys kind of thought about
that look yeah i think i was just going
to say that actually
because i was just i i've looked at i
would glance at these but i've been
looking deep at them now i'm like okay
those look just like the rocket launcher
looks like a rocket launcher
but i mean they look cool though still
i like the way they look yeah it's like
if those are the seasonal weapons
they're cool they're like a mix of you
know whatever's going on and then
obviously the gold
nature with the the cabal so i'm good
yeah but they're like always leaving out
something like there's no hand cannon
there and there's no pulse rifle why do
they always do that
yeah they always did it yeah like you
couldn't just add it a couple like i
guess maybe because
midnight koopal had been like what well
that would have been sick can you
imagine a new version
but it you've also got two other things
coming that are hand cannons so
that's true that's true i think that
it's it's left
out purposely based on like
weapon need that remember because they
took out so much from the pool
yeah so i think that's what is as far as
giving us the full set in this new
format
i think obviously the hand cannons like
he said we've gotten a lot you know what
i mean so probably that
but yeah i think so but yeah these i
like that i mean again the one looks
like a dead ringer for six uh since in
the past the rocket
but um yeah that's the closest the
design it's like some more aztec
feel i'm digging it i'm digging the
design i'm gonna front the
this season designs even when you talk
about the armors as much like i'm
feeling that old
there's some dreams version golf ball
okay by the way shout out to chat and
justin
you have ruined me for the titan helmet
by the way and i
can't un see it all i'm gonna say is the
word hitachi and if you can't figure it
out from there
go figure it out but the titan helmet
and then he paired it with the cr the
trials ghost
and i'm done i am so done because the
trials ghost some people are saying
looks resemblance of something
yes and then you have the hitachi helmet
and it's just i'm out i am so done
it's hilarious oh god it just broke me
so i'm like well i officially cannot
wear that helmet ever
ever again he's at the time he'd help me
have something pleasing
no you can't see it you can't let's see
it man yeah they look like clowns they
have the ball some people are saying
they're persian armor which i was like
okay i kind of looked up some of that i
can see
and again like the hunter the hunter
helm is the only one that i can say
looks like
clean it's got like the ringer on the
head for like the and kind of the drapes
down the face and stuff like that is
so crazy i like the design this season i
win it man
oh wait a little bit almost like the
season
pass armor just like the leather is like
so bland though
yeah that one yeah that is that's just
like the perfectness the perfectest
yeah that's basically but like the gold
and what
i gotta ask what the hell is on the
titan's back
what is that three-point looking
what is it what is it i'm gonna fire you
gotta beat you with my walking stick
like what the hell
and i like i got the zavala shoulder pad
that joy looked funny i i like
you know what i'm saying that they look
hot yeah y'all soon look hot to me i
added um
the the hunter it almost got like this
you know what it look like e
when we playing ghost is your ship you
know how the mongolians had that helmet
when you're fighting them
yeah i thought it was my goal yeah
that's what that down to
my little snowball at the time
it's unique i like the style like they
they bad culturally with this i'm with
this one
it looks funny yeah i'm managing chat at
the same time
it kind of looks like it kind of looks
like they took
the um
you guys are probably like do you play
this game look why don't you know the
names of any of these weapons
like they took um go big it looks like
they took sweet business
and just took it apart and put it on
yeah yes
like it's one of the cool yeah one of
the cool pieces of it
that's so weird that like shoulder piece
on the left though he's trying to like
rival zavala's shoulder
and i will say warlocks you can calm
down with the collar poppage because
that is just yeah
that's a lot of trouble that is a lot of
columns i don't know
we definitely ranked number three
yeah yes yes i i would have to agree
tight number one hunter number two and
then we're third here
i don't hate it you know compared to
y'alls yeah
you oh i heard somebody said it was like
you could probably take pieces of this
yeah like with transmog and a shaker
yeah you can have some fun
i will never wear the titan helmet but
man i wish we had something like i like
that
that's just fine somebody asked me what
is the hitbox on that helmet by the way
yeah for real can you hit the top of
that thing it's a hedgehog if you hit
the ball
off the top like oh my god there was
another one where it's the golf emote in
front of the golf ball and the team oh
my gosh like they're the memes were fast
on the on these that was oh yeah it was
crazy
i love it i love it justice with me
he said he never take it i'm with you
for that y'all got it man i like it i
like i like when they go over the top
sometimes and tight it's kind of fun
quick take for you guys i know we won't
know until we get our hands on them
three person match made battlegrounds
are you excited are you like
what are your thoughts just like quick
and quick and quick and dirty
seems like the whole theme of this
episode at this point
i i feel like it's gonna be cool but i
would i like it personally if they did
like nine man activities
i like whenever you want to get
everywhere that's when you drop off old
gen consoles when you can use that new
hardware that's when you get
crazy stuff yeah yeah
no quick you know match made okay fine
but
would have loved six but you know it is
what it is you know i'm saying i mean
at least they're different locations and
we'll see you know
what the the mechanics are i'm just
think you know long as he's not throwing
balls at a target
all that
one of the other pieces is the helm so
it seems like a new kind of social space
you've got your hammer of proving which
to everybody's understanding seems to be
like
the crypto little lure or chalice of
opulence
seems to be like your seasonal slot
things in going to battlegrounds
i'm guessing that's what that's going to
be like so i'll be more curious about
the social space because people are
rumored about the tower coming back and
it looks like it might be a piece of the
window
oh snap that looks like that is the
tower right there right right yeah
that's
so and then i just saw it for the first
time just now
on top of his destiny information
for a while he gets a pass he's getting
busy
i just like i i get to stream at night
and i'm like gaming
and then during the day i like glance at
this stuff but yeah
i'm glad that i'm seeing this right now
it's my real life reaction
i think it's coming back i think that's
maybe that's how next season starts
i don't know maybe it starts with a cut
scene of it being like
we're open again and everyone's clapping
and
that's a good rumor because there's this
thing called a cube map which i guess is
kind of it
i don't remember exactly what those are
used for but it was a cube map of the
old tower roaming around the game
yep so and there's they showed what was
like
if you went slow did the tower and went
straight back in the back i think that
was the open kind of garden area
that was like shown in the cube map
section but if you look up the window
has almost a similar shape to the helm
room so
i don't know where we're going to be
going at some point i feel like
um we will get back there sorry i just
messed with chat right now
they just put a big bridge from our
tower to that tower that you walk across
that's the part where like the music's
really slow you have to walk slow so
you're like walking across the wall to
go from our section on the wall to the
tower
very dramatic and then they add
a thing where it just you know like
those little rooms that you go in and
then the air blows you up to the next
spot they just gotta do a thing where
you go
you fly over there that'd be sick
and the most unimportant part of the
game uh a social space
[Laughter]
they're like well we didn't add any maps
but we added all this sick stuff to the
social
space social space social space there's
fire in here you can't do anything can
you shoot trigger
no you have a firing range no you got
rid of the menagerie
and the training hall and dammit
at some point they need to add like a
shooting range back in the game because
they got the
tribute hall which maybe the helm is
like the tribute hall but it's in the
tower so it's like a tribute hall that
they don't want to because they probably
got came out the tribute hall are like
crap this is way cooler than we thought
it was going to be
useful yeah but it's not in the in the
tower which would have made a lot of
sense to have like a place where you can
go and watch
this shooting enemies it's interesting
i'm very curious to see what what this
actually is you know this helm comes
online
you know is it some type of war strategy
thing
is it you know some kind of it would be
dope
yeah it had some type of you know
training thing in it too a lot of
possibilities
i'm very curious to see what that is and
then also where the uh the umbrellas
where that whole thing's gonna go down
it looks like it's in the floor of it if
you look at the
calendar it looks like it's like on the
other side of that long room
for the helm table and then the
prismatic recasters in the floor
so yeah i'm hoping this thing isn't hard
to get to
right because if you got to go there
every time for your umbrellas and you
have to load into a separate space of
the tower i think we're all going to go
a little crazy
yes i'm hoping it's somewhat
consolidated a little simpler to get to
and around so we'll just have to see
where they put everything
yeah do you know what's one thing i
noticed at the
in inside because i'm on the web i think
i've been on the wall i haven't been on
this website the whole time we've been
talking about this and now i'm looking
at all this stuff on
welcome to the party i'm like what are
they looking at i don't see any of this
in the tops
but the picture like right before they
show included with season the chosen
it's
it's the emperor empress's helmet by
itself
yes why is that do you guys why do you
think that's there
yeah no it's a very interesting choice i
did notice that as well like what's that
about
like why that's literally kaitl's
helmet so i'm just like okay
okay that's it i mean keep the helmet on
please
probably like every season they do like
a
concept art piece theme for the season
that they've done yeah so they have like
the when it was i think it was season of
the worthy where it was like the sword
dagger whatever was like your artifact
yeah yeah you're right you're right so i
think they always have that kind of
conceptual artist piece and that looks
okay
that's what it is because you have the
same thing from the urn and you've got
every helmet so it's like
kind of what's the nature of the season
and i think that's just like the concept
art which is always
you're right because they did that with
um i just remembered a cool one like
that
with opulence where they had the the at
the time we didn't know the offstringer
had the grapes and they had the thing
you know it was like very
the whole getting into the whole
menagerie thing and it was very yeah
i think it's just like you said it's a
conceptual theme of the season as
opposed to
maybe a direct action that's going to
happen in the season
that makes sense sweet just checking
what is that doing get everybody on the
same page where's the point she's going
to take it off
she's in the she's on the leviathan
taking a bath
on a complete side note since this
podcast has been half dirty anyway thank
you guys for the um
memes yes the resident evil lady
who is apparently nine foot six inches
tall with heels and hat
people want to get i love paul tassie
he's like why do people want to get
stepped on by this lady and it's just
like
it's killing me on the inside because i
also feel that old too and i'm like that
doesn't seem great i know what you're
saying but the wording is weird
yes and then apparently kaitlyn they
said is what nine
foot ten so they're like now we're all
comparing boss sizes and stuff like that
i'm like where's oryx in his final form
he's got to be like 50 feet like five
stories tall or something
crazy um
random height stuff going around in the
world of video game comparisons it's
very hilarious
um but this is what i want to do so i'm
going to list off the calendar weeks
and then i want you guys to give me your
feedback when i finish it up
okay okay so week one two battlegrounds
two strikes helm comes online
okay start of the season also in week
one stasis quest
first weekend trials got it week two
one battleground week three
one battleground um i don't even know if
i should say iron banner because we know
it's gonna be in there so iron banner's
in there three times a season
deal with it right one month later if
you have the season pass you get the new
strike
a week after that then the strike enters
the nightfall playlist
and then a month later you have guardian
games
that's the calendar right so you have
week one week two week three of
battlegrounds
a month later you have a strike and then
a month later you have guardian games
thoughts enough not enough cool yay nay
cheers booze what's what's the audience
what's the what's the audience sound
right now
what's the gladiator thing
unfortunately i think it's going to make
people are very upset now with how
things are and there was a new
expansion at the beginning of the season
uh so i'm thinking
it's gonna be a really slow few months
for them for the hardcore players i
think the the
the casual people will have plenty of
stuff to work on but
yeah uh it just seems like drip content
again while they're trying to get to the
next
thing which i've i'm fine with like
there's new stuff coming it'll give me a
reason to log in and play this new stuff
and then i'm basically like i get real
hyped into
i play i play i play i play a lot i get
really hardcore when there's an
expansion
because it's you know like the actual
dlc
yeah but like i we were just saying
earlier like if there was more pvp stuff
added in here it would keep the end game
flowing for a lot of people so
i think that there's going to be a big
void there again this season where
trials isn't going to be the only thing
that cuts it for everyone unfortunately
and i think there's me a lot of angry
people by the end of the season once
again
which i don't like when that happens
because i like it when things are more
positive but
i'm excited personally but i think it's
gonna i think that there's not enough
stuff on this calendar
even if i mean they put so many they
even they put so many like little words
everywhere i'm like yeah to make it look
like there's so much stuff but then when
you were just saying that out loud
i was like dang a month and then there's
something else a month and then there's
something else like oh my goodness
yeah we need to forget about it yeah
when you take off the top of like new
exotics new ornaments new story content
guardian games umbral engrams like
that's all like pve iron banners listed
on there and you're like
i get it iron banner's on there seasonal
challenges or something and actually
somebody said like
if you take the seasonal challenges and
you kind of go like week by week as they
get less and less
i'd be curious to see where all of those
fall but before i say anything else cog
like just hearing the season described
that way or however you like to say it
what are your thoughts on the seasonal
calendar how's it how does it feel on
first glance
i'm okay with it but um i'm still
holding out for
right underneath where it says may seven
through nine and more
so i think my guts still sell me they
got like a secret
they still got a secret cooking because
a month two
a month gap two times
right did you say it was like a month or
something between
um yeah february 23rd to march 23rd
there is
roughing that's a month right that's a
month right
march 23rd which you'll already have the
strike the week later but march 23rd to
april 20th which is about another four
weeks
guardian games comes which is right
right
anyway but yeah so that's about another
month after the one strike is introduced
like yeah you've got some gaps to fill
there's gaps there's good
i think normally i don't get optimistic
with them with this but i do
think they are holding on to something i
think i don't want to get you too
excited it's that dungeon or something
but they're they're holding on to
something cause that's
two months of not anything happening
substantial
and i'm saying so yeah they're holding
on to something and
again the timing seems about right you
know i'm saying okay we had the raid
last time we didn't have a dungeon
this time you know we know vaulted
glasses on the horizon is not ready
right now for this season i do think
there will be something i i just
i don't know if it it it may only be
like a zero hour kind of situation it
may not be the dungeon
you know what i'm saying so i'm just i'm
tempering my expectation on the
how big whatever that thing is but i do
believe
you can't have a two-month gap without
you fitting something in there that
they're just not ready to talk about
right now because it would be a dead
giveaway to whatever this thing is
yeah so that's it and the last point
i'll say shout out to the check and i
just about to say it
was that'd be nice if uh guardian games
could uh
look like they got some racing style
suits there
don't even get your hopes up i'm gonna
say that don't even you know
if um you it guardian game being an
olympic kind of thing in a competitive
thing
would be nice if that acrobative that we
all love nope don't even say it could
get go in the game because i would love
me some srl i don't know you said it
yeah let's
that would for real make the most that
would be like because last year's
guardian games was so lame i didn't even
do it
i think that srl
would be this would be the best time to
bring it back
you got me hyped you got me hyped now
they better bring it back or imma cry
and it fits the mat thematically with
with guardian gangs
olympics racing you know what i'm saying
like it'll be funny
exactly they have the vault let's use
some old assets to bring it forward
hey i can hope i can dream i've got i'll
push it for this one
srl come on baby because it says that
guardian what's the closing ceremony for
going
why do we need a closing ceremony
shows up there's like uh fireworks
that's it
present the little statue
hey i can dream i could hope i could
dream you're really no titans have
already won so they'll give us our baby
statue in the
guardians game ceremony no honestly
believe me
i would love probably more than a lot of
people to see
sparrow srl back sparrow racing league
because i had a lot of fun with it
but again if you have to take the
realistic check and say
we already got a new strike we didn't
expect that we're getting trials weapons
trials armor
we know they're working on witch queen
yeah we got battlegrounds we got four of
them spaced out yeah they kind of
you know fancied up some patrol spaces
but still
they put those in there the mechanics
are in there has smallest seasons have
felt and
feel like they can only get so big right
one reason i don't want it to be here
because i want it to be permanent if it
comes back i swear to god if it's in the
game for three weeks and leaves oh it's
it's not it's leaving
it's leaving they holding on to that
thing they're going they're gonna milk
that thing to the wheels you are not
getting a permanent
sro i can guarantee you bring it back
don't bring it back tease me and be like
gone again for another five
years don't do it i don't even want to
see it again i i don't want to see it
i don't want to see it if it's only
three weeks just didn't have to do it
because that'll be getting people
then they'd be like it only comes around
you know it comes around
this is the the seasonal bottle the fomo
were you there with yes i
can literally get away from fomo
listen they gonna tie it to an event and
the perfect event would be guardian
games if you're gonna bring it back
guardian gays is the event to do it and
you're gonna take care
of experiencing league for three weeks
i'm gonna revolt i'm gonna throw
this
have we been asking for this thing to
come back and if it's back for
three weeks are you kidding me you'll be
happy
no i'd be so pissed
i mean it would be interesting whatever
it comes back it's going to be
interesting in the form it comes back
but it would be cool i think that would
be a nice little cabash you know i was
like but honestly with the bandwidth i
don't see it at all i would not get your
experience realistically probably not
you know
but if i got a hope because my thing is
what you got a ceremony for well
ceremony for what
like what what what is why we need a
closing game closing ceremony
for what is it 73 days what's happening
in three days that we need to
just to close what do we need that for
like good job you put you guys put as a
bunch of things and you press the button
and put a bunch of things in this box
you guys congrats congrats like again
and more and more
it's like apple it's like apple's one
more thing
yes we bungees one more thing oh i'm
telling you the air
the and more is likely the quest that
they haven't put a date on
probably because there's the text
mechanic redacted
not on the calendar so they're not going
to give you the you know
dawning quarters of time bastian they're
not doing that stuff anymore they're
going to keep a few things
close to the chest see how it's going
but yeah
why they need a closing ceremony it's
like all right day one
third place celebrate your day date like
i don't know
now how do you guys want guardian games
to work that's the better question
what did we do last year i can't even
remember what we did what we did for the
statue for the statue y'all won
what was it like dude strikes
and then you put the things in the i
don't remember actually i'd literally
that was the only time i didn't get the
exotic that was available
i got it at the beginning of this season
because you could buy it from the kiosk
but right
it was right yep yeah some people are
saying these catalysts
okay they said yeah we did bounties yeah
but they were like the ultra specific
get like melee kills with the titan and
it was just the optimization that like
people were like well titans can punch
easier than the rest of us for these
bounties we need ability kills or
whatever
yeah so that's why i was saying
functionality how would you how would
you guys like to just see like hunter
versus
hunter forsyth versus warlock how would
you guys like to see
a in-game competition held like take out
whatever happened before
how do you think would be a good way to
do that
oh like legit race like you know in uh
leviathan whenever we were in the room
where you
what was that called the the room the
gauntlet like
have actual racing like where you're
running and you're jumping through stuff
you shoot something you jump like
obstacle courses and stuff like i would
think that would be more like
games than than just like did i did more
bounties than you like that's
yeah that doesn't that to me is not
competition they still that's why i said
srl we need direct competition like this
what this bounty thing i'm like i like
the concept of it
i like the aesthetic look of my of
guardian games
i like the idea of a trophy i like the
bragging rights aspect
but getting millions of people to just
do bounties that's not
really it when i i don't feel like i
think what is it to say to chat like
you gotta lock the player in to the
class almost like
i don't know you gotta you gotta do
something it just that really
meet makes it feel like we're competing
against the other classes like
i don't really look at bounty turnings
as oh i'm beating you you know saying
like
you know like it just i mean it was cool
yeah you talking today you see the
little
what was it the statues would go up or
whatever it was that went up the flag
right yeah and then one day you see the
titans to the moon you know kind of
thing and it's just like okay
cool but bounty turning on its own
should not be enough in my opinion
no i mean believe me i'm with you it's
like i wish there was a way they would
just like track
what each class does in the game for
three weeks but if you go do a raid like
you beat an encounter it's where there's
a certain number of points you go finish
a raid it's worth this like
and whatever classes are involved in
doing that so if you want to play on
your hunter for three weeks to support
them
everything you do throughout the game
strike is worth this trials flawless
it's worth this
raid finish worth like everything just a
total point accumulation
right yeah and then maybe on certain
maybe on weekends you get bonus points
or maybe in the final week you get like
a boost in point so if you're a little
behind but you can make a final push
switch to that character
that's the only thing i can think of
that would be like a general way of
still playing the game but being like
you know
how's it going as you go through another
thing i was thinking like in pvp this
mode that they're not using
um how about how many hunters did you
kill how many
warlocks did you kill you know what i'm
saying that's true wait put it
tie it to the actual competition of who
you're fighting in like just they got to
make it
they gotta narrow it down man every
every hunter you kill is the titan is
minus points to a hunter
so then everybody's just being crucible
doing this plus and minus thing hunter's
going to win that one for sure
i know we do add br to it i'm just
kidding
it's about a royal mode
drop us drop us where we dropping boys
somewhere in the edz
or something hey man make it happen that
would actually be interesting to see
what a
br looks like that would be crazy you've
been some good rigs to battle to see
like
nova bombs going back
you hear zavala like the way it starts
balls like there's this new trend
happening in the city called
brs so we're gonna try it oh god i can
only imagine lance radek reading that
voice line
oh yeah the kids are playing this game
called fortnite
whether we want it or not whether we
want it or not
you can now construct blocks to get
around the area
it's gonna be an interesting season
because when they're gonna put in these
gaps man but
we gotta see we gotta see man i think we
in the
most weird roundabout way we seem to
have touched on just about everything
yeah is there anything else you guys
want to talk about because
time-wise we've hit a longer episode
that's a lot is there anything that we
haven't talked about or
you know final final thoughts as we go
into
it's tuesday so any final thoughts
before we go into tuesday
uh it's chicken pot pineap tuesday i say
that every tuesday i don't know why
but i have an emote that is a chicken
pot pie and then there's a tuesday on
top of it i've been saying that for a
long time
so chicken potatoes tuesday today's not
tuesday though today's friday i just
remembered that
you just said it was tuesday you had me
believing it was tuesday
we gotta get this big back
man you got to be careful how much news
and stuff you take in you might be
might be taking the wrong information
there i'll be like by the way trials
you're going to play that from tuesday
through
thursday just just make sure you look
for it it'll be there for you
i'll be there you guys better be there
i'll be right there in your backpack
oh man good job right
shout out to concealer game yeah for me
i i'm just so i'm actually excited i
want to see about what the
if there's any sandbox on the patch day
i want to see
what the i'm actually curious about the
artifact i want to see
what's the trends for this you know what
are they going to push us towards
as far as unstoppable and all that good
stuff i thought last season's
um the surge joint where you um stun
a champion and then the other bond that
you get the grenade i thought that was a
very cool addition
i want to see if they continue with um
that and um
yeah i mean i think i think we do get a
secret e
i know you're looking at those two bumps
and i know you you're feeling away i i
hear to your voice you're like
no it's like this month gap twice
what do you think you know listen i i do
think there will be something
i think it'll be cool but i just don't
know the scale of it i just don't know
it could be something as small as a
let's say small but something is
a zero hour or whatever you know kind of
thing a secret mission
or it could very well be what you know
that whole osiris thing at the end where
it's like there's no light in here in
where what's going on and where this
place you're at
guardian go investigate it becomes
dungeon or something
and then you know yeah shout out
oppressive darkness yes i want an
impressive darkness back too for my
artifact thank you
yeah shout out dramatic but um yeah and
i think you know trials will get a shot
in the arm that it needs
you know we'll see how it plays out and
then my thing is i'm with you luke
i'm all about the narrative flow of this
season
that's all i care about to be honest
cato the role
crow his role how close is he getting
you know to accept it obviously zavala
just met him that interaction has to
happen
what's that about you know what i'm
saying and then also if y'all saw the
lore
that came out that left out of the game
that they wrote on the website
that um you know osiris is mentoring
them like one exile to another this is
how
at some point we're gonna face this all
right first
take those black clothes that you got
off of me let me hook you up with some
uh syrian drip so you see my boy out
here to go you're looking fly you know
what i'm saying so osiris is his mentor
and i like that aspect i like what
they're doing with that and the last
thing will be
the eventual alliance we are going to
ally with the cabal
and then where and also zevo wrath
yeah we pushed it back a little bit
what's up with that you know where that
goes to i'm curious so i think for me
it's
this is the law to drag us through and
one secret i i
hold out hopefully one secret that
you're gonna be excited i'm predicting
you're gonna be like okay
this is what i'm talking about yeah and
then we'll be all right and then then
you'll be pleased
fair enough then boom youtube video maps
youtube video
[Laughter]
they're good they're good for that uh
for me honestly like one of the things
that i totally forgot to touch on so i'm
just gonna say it really quickly
um the aeon cult
exotics oh we didn't even talk about
that i know we don't have a ton of time
but
basically all classes are gonna have the
same exotic i don't know if it's just
gonna be a on cult or whatever it's
called
and you will all have mods that you can
choose now the mods work
and i think the idea of this is cool um
definitely one of the best
reworks for an exotic that i've probably
seen so
each mod has one perk for you and one
perk for your allies
and has extra benefits if they aren't
wearing the same perk so there's
benefits to everybody
basically a three person fire team each
takes one is what you would eventually
want
sector force rapid precision hits with a
weapon temporarily increase your reload
speed and weapon swap speed
when you stun a champion or defeat a
boss or mini boss your nearby fire team
members gain a burst of grenade and
melee energy
aeon caught allies who do not have the
sector force
also gain a burst of super energy so if
i finish off a champion or a boss
you guys get grenade melee and super
energy if you're not wearing the same
thing
so if you're going to be like hey
everybody okay you take the last one
finish them up cool everybody gets a
boost
sect of insight uh you've got successive
precision weapon takedowns
have a chance to drop an orb of power
for your allies
when you finish a when you use a
finisher on an elite which
i think that's at least an orange bar
above uh you generate special ammo for
your fire team
when you use a finisher on a boss or
mini boss so i guess elite's different
uh you generate heavy ammo for your fire
team so again you have certain people
who need to do boss skills do you need
energy cool
you need we need ammo you go finish the
boss nearby aeon cult allies who do not
have the sect of insight
also gain a bonus to weapon damage for a
short time
right that one only i could see
um see again it's like hard to know if
those are on
all the time or when you do the
finishers you get those right
finally the sect of vigor uh gain class
ability energy as your allies die
gain full class ability energy when you
resurrect an ally
um i could see that on other rifts or
titans probably being beneficial less so
for a hunter in a pve situation
and most of this all seems very pve
related these don't seem like they're
going to do a ton for pvp
when you cast your super nearby allies
gain an instant burst of healing
that's actually cool that's probably the
only one that would work in pvp to go
down
trials that's going to go down sector
vega trials
aeon cult allies who do not have the
sector vigor role equipped
also gain an overshield nice so i mean
like
that one alone could be really
interesting like if you're the strong
player and you're the one who's going to
be doing the resin area
you knew that and you just got a lot
stronger so
conceptually like aeon cult's probably
like the worst
everybody hated them forever like they
were just like i had a 68 69 roll and i
don't think i kept that because it was
that
i'm in the same boat i deleted all those
i would be so disgusted would i get that
exotic
i just normally i never even if it's
something i hate i always
keep it yeah for some reason not exotic
i'm mad i don't have
any now no and what what's the one i'm
assuming the one from collections is
trash right yeah that's trash you could
pull it but yeah it'll be in the 40s or
something like 48 is there ever
never uh i mean he has he's definitely
sold it so you never know
if he sells it this week is this is one
of those times where he knows there's
the randomness is kind of [ __ ] we
don't know about him
you know about him you know he's been
compromised but like i will but i will
say like
this type of we've talked about exotic
armor and a lot of exotics armor and
weapons
sit on a dusty shelf right and i think
this is a cool
this more often like type of unique
reworks and this is a very unique
situation because you have the
set that worked together but whether it
works out
i don't know how it's going to be like
in action i don't know if there's
they're going to really be big payoffs
but at least in concept i really really
like what they did here
yeah so that's like kind of my one big
takeaway is like
the the look at an exotic to do that now
it's one set and there's still a bunch
that said dusty but for the time being
like
you took one of the worst and you
definitely are gonna make people test it
out try it out and look at builds that
work the best because it's going to get
it all of those seem to have interesting
moments to them which is cool
yeah blue yeah i think the idea of this
is my favorite
not not exactly these specifically but
the idea of exotic
armor working together because the whole
point of what they want us to do is
play as a fire team they they want us to
play with our friends and a really cool
way to be a fire team is to
you know be you know working together
with not only ourselves but with our
gear which
i love the ability to build you can do
even
more like builds of armor when it comes
to like not just like builds for
yourself but then like fire team builds
like if we're in a gm if they had like
specific armor where it was like if
we're in a gm
and you kill a champion then all your
armor does this and
if if one guy kills a champion then you
all have i don't know there's like a
million options that you could
do from this i think this is good
groundwork for hopefully future exotic
armor that they bring out
that makes you work as a team
differently because your armor is
actually affecting the way that you play
i think that'd be pretty sweet
bridge we appreciate it yeah i mean i
always felt that
these type of things that they first
introduced were always half baked
i didn't feel like they were fully
realized
they tried they tried a lot of it if you
remember they tried a lot like rat king
six people have a rat king you know they
tried these team oriented things and it
just didn't
hit and now this is a again i'm always a
fan look at you they're big on
statistics and usage rate
look at the under we know this thing was
in the bushes
nobody was using this thing right yeah
so
look at your usage rate bring it back to
the table
rework it even if it's just one exotica
season that you just look
if you don't have the resources to do a
whole bunch that we know that need
touching up
i like this you know angel swift deserve
this this is dope
i'm very excited i think the figure is
going to be great for pvp and
like night falls again with the superior
carrying player
there's a lot of uses i mean the other
stuff with the champion and stuff like
that
or it it it's getting me into a build
mode
yep i understand i can now okay i might
be
now adorned but i mean uh well of
radiance warlock my whole thing is
healing and i take one of these things
and i'm really supporting and then i
like to even support people who don't
wear it
but if you all wear it the benefits and
the synergy start kicking
my only requirement go grab your aon
piece and you're like i'm sorry
yeah yeah you said get you yeah you
you you go under my wing you're in my
backpack you need to put this on
if you want to get this done like i like
it it's potential you know
again what like luke said is this my
favorite thing i'm always going to be
rushing to it probably
not all the time i'm going to try it but
i want to see more of the
the concept of reworking non-used
exotics anymore the usage rate is very
low
that stuff excites me i love when bungie
does this they don't do
enough of it so this is dope
well that's about all we got i think so
we can wrap up the episode
um this is the point in the time where
luke the floor is yours
where people can find you what you got
going on what you're looking to be
working on
platforms basically anybody who listens
this is your time how do they find you
what do you do what do you want to do
all that good stuff sweet well i stream
on twitch i have a schedule now
so i i just started this week and i
really like it i stream on twitch
on monday tuesday wednesday friday
around 11
p.m eastern standard time until late
just depends
sometimes i start at 10 but i always
just say 11 because i'm usually late
and then i have a youtube channel
uh just search beard luke or i think
it's youtube.combeardluke
uh i have a lot of content there right
now it's pokemon content but it's gonna
be it's a mixture of
you know gaming content creation how
to's studio stuff just like a bun it's
going to be a bunch of stuff i'm still
starting it
it's not going to be like honed in on
one thing it's going to be like kind of
just based off what i like
so i'm working on that which i'm excited
about this year just i'm making a video
right now about my
new setup down here which is exciting to
to do and then
uh i the twitch is just twitch.tv slash
beer to luke i love hanging out on
twitter so if
if if i love talking to people on
twitter it's my favorite social media
because i control it
it's just games for me so uh
it's just like the bearded luke because
the regular
whoever took bearded luke on twitter
doesn't use their account and won't give
it to me
[Music]
and um we have a podcast called uh
the destiny nerds podcast on at 10 p.m
on uh
sundays at 10 p.m eastern standard time
i'd love to have both of you on there at
some point by the way
seriously because we have guests every
week we like to have content creators
from the destiny community come in so we
can
get to know them personally but also
just it's so cool you guys do it you
know it's
this is it like we're all talking about
destiny from different perspectives it's
interesting it's fun
i've enjoyed sitting here talking to you
guys and get to know both of you now i
feel like we're
we're buddies like best buddies i want
to give
you guys more facts brother you blew my
mind when you told me the guardian khan
story it's so funny how
well passed crossed you know what i mean
it was just so cool
exactly and and content-wise that's
that's basically all i'm doing that's
where you can find me
uh if you like gamer subs use code
bearded luke for 10
off he's got to plug it
yeah he's pushing me yeah they're good
they give me lots of energy
uh actually they're so good that i've
had to pee for the past like hour and a
half but i'm holding it hard
you know you can be like you pee gotta
be back
okay yeah you guys talk i'm going to
knock out my stuff really quick
sorry i'm going to be receiving your
points today because we're short on time
i got five minutes still there so
you guys keep going low down you already
do shout out to radeem for making uh e
this is the part of the show and you
know like i said he's got to get that
work
in you know during the weather you've
been you've been at home kovitz keep me
in the house and uh
you got to still work out man you got to
still work that's what we do here luke
you know so he we had the last but we
still got to promote
the fitness thing and getting look at
the perfect form
i love this you don't get this type of
premium entertainment from any nesting
pocket
this is what we're doing we're promoting
that positive physical lifestyle here
right
you want to have the last word not only
and that's if you want to have the last
word with your physicality wouldn't be
good out here
so make sure you get the sit-ups in
they're making them dab they're making
them do all types of stuff
just to say that's what we do baby
you're saying so look man
ease of inspiration out here giving us
what we need you could have used this
time for the pee break by the way bro
i could have i'll just wait i'll pee oh
you're a strong man that's a strong
bladder
i was like i'm over here chugging water
and i'm just like this
you know what i'm saying making
everything yeah there you go there's the
red face that we miss
that's a strong man right there
there we go that's that that's that they
tell you to hydrate they they want you
to um to get your dab on
hydrating dab that's what they're saying
right now he said just said this is why
we suff
this is
[Music]
we're breaking it down and um yeah bad
for me like i said i just want to shout
you guys out real quick um
thanks for the uh positive messages
obviously i didn't get the greatest
medical news this week but um you know
definitely just going to battle through
it thinking positively and um
doing what i got to do um so uh again
everyone who sent me a message
on on the situation i really appreciate
it it meant a lot and uh yeah i'm gonna
fight this thing and see what happens
with that i'll keep you guys posted
posted on my progress but as far as on
me
you already know atla cognito on twitter
ironworldpodcast on youtube this sunday
will be a fun
show we're going to have lasercorn on
lasercorn formally of uh smosh podcast
fun guest hilarious um he he
he's he's a good guy to create you gotta
get you guys gonna like this kid
so come check us out sunday it will be
at 1 p.m eastern
on youtube you know what i'm saying and
um yeah man again the last word is good
to be back talking destiny hype new
trailer
marketing department in full effect the
hype is here and i got some hope that
it's going we're gonna have a secret for
e
and then he's gonna be he gonna be happy
that's what i got
but again justin everybody see you guys
bended thank you yeah thank you i saw
the
the messages you guys sent me this week
it meant a lot you know to see everybody
kind of pulling
pull up for me with my situation so
thank you guys much love you already
know
sorry breathing
uh but no honestly thank you guys as
well very much it's always fun to do
this you guys try and kill me at the end
of each episode so that's why you guys
stay to the end
so if you don't ever if you catch one of
these on youtube you catch them on
you know audio platforms itunes spotify
wherever you listen to it try and catch
them live because the episodes are
always a blast but chat you guys have
been on fire today thank you guys very
much
as i breathe heavily through this thing
it's totally fine luke sir man i'm so
glad we got you on it has been a blast
as you said like you spend
this long of a podcast together you're
like man i gotta play with this guy it's
like so cool and see and all that fun
stuff
so um but it was a blast like didn't
know you're hit you have one of the most
unique histories into destiny
i've probably heard yeah definitely i
loved it
no i'm not gonna play no i'm not gonna
play yeah it almost felt like
you know like like you know you end up
getting married to your partner
like he was rejecting this girl for like
bad
persistent she just times hanging around
and then he ends up like
oh yo i really like this guy yeah i
really like this version you know i'm
gonna marry them
yeah like they're like yeah you paid it
nobody
it's so funny yeah but yeah you guys are
having me yeah absolutely absolutely man
um and definitely you're always welcome
back so
yes any time and obviously check out his
podcast destiny nerds gotta help him get
that one
yeah we just started we just had episode
i think this week's episode eleven so
nice
wow remember that we got eleven episodes
that was fun times for destiny there but
uh the curse of osiris jesus
but for me it's ivantis twitch twitter
youtube uh follow me on twitter
for my streaming schedule i need to post
that on youtube as well
uh but i am streaming some on youtube so
on twitch i've been working through
immortals phoenix rising that's been a
blast it's like
i haven't played a ton of assassin's
creed games like basically hardly any
so it's kind of cool to do like the
adventure game especially after playing
hades in the greek gods so i've been
working through that it's fun
um and then yeah everybody's like
wondering when hellblade
and uh what's the other one plaguetale
um yeah both of those people want to see
me play so
follow me you guys will know what i'm
playing yeah hellblade i'm gonna play
a couple definitely gonna happen whether
it's twitch youtube
streaming on both you guys know where to
find me on there like subscribe follow
both of these gentlemen all of what they
do so
spread the love thank you guys very much
today chad has been on fire
and we can wrap this thing up because we
got other stuff to do so
yes thank you guys very much episode 135
february 5th
our guest bearded luke thank you for
your time sir we kept you for
a full full three hours here so that
bladder yeah
yeah we got we got the whole time used
up um but for this episode thank you all
thank you chat you guys have been
amazing
and have an awesome day it has been
the last word